SAID ASSEMBLY LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE AM SO
HAPPY TO BE HERE IN LA-
CONVENING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THAT'S FOCUSING ON
BUILDING A SECURE FUTURE FOR
WORKERS TRAINING RETRAINING AND
REMOVING EMPLOYMENT BARRIERS
AND- VERY HAPPY TO BE JOINED
TODAY BY A COUPLE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE READING AND SALAS
AND AS A MEMBER OF LOOSE RIVAS-
I'M ALSO VERY HAPPY TO HAVE
WITH THE SENATOR MEMBERS LYDIA.
SO AND- AND JUST GRATEFUL FOR
ALL OF THEM FOR BEING HERE. IN
AN FOR HOLDING THESE HEARINGS
AND DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
STATE SO IT'S GREAT. APPETITE
IS A PATIENT. EVER WE CAN FROM
BOTH MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE
OTHER THAN THE MEMBERS ONLY MAY
HAVE. DROPPING BY AS WELL AS OF
COURSE ARE AND I COLLEAGUES I
CARE DEEPLY. THESE ISSUES. I'M
AS WE CONTINUE OUR SERIES OF
HEARINGS ON THE FUTURE OF WORK
WITH THE WITH THE DEEP DIVE
INTO WORKER TRAINING
INITIATIVES- FOR POPULATIONS
THAT BASS BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. SUCH AS THE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED IMMIGRANT
WORKERS AND LOW WAGE WORKERS-
OUR PANELISTS WERE POINT OUT-
WORKER TRAINING FOR
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES HAS
BECOME A ROBUST AREA OF
GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY BASED AND
PRIVATE PARTICIPATION. AND
OVERALL OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM CARS CLOSE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN TRAINING
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS CASE
MANAGERS AND JOB PLACEMENT
COORDINATORS. A PART OF THE
GOAL OF TODAY'S HEARING IS TO
AND UNDERSTAND HOW ALL THESE
PIECES FIT TOGETHER AND DISCUSS
WAYS TO MAKE THIS COLLABORATION
EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE AND IT'S
CERTAINLY AN AREA- HAVING BEEN
A FORMER DEPUTY UP DEFENDER.
AND NOW IN MY ROOM THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND WAYS TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IS PART OF OUR ECONOMY AND HOW
CAN WE DO THAT MOST
EFFECTIVELY. BEFORE I
INTRODUCED THE FIRST PANEL
THAT'S JOINED US ON THE STAGE
LIKE GET THE OPPORTUNITY
ATTENDING MY COLLEAGUES THAT
THEY LIKE TO MAKE ANY WELCOMING
REMARKS OR ANY COMMENTS. ON THE
TOPIC OF TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. OKAY I'M THEY'RE HERE
TO LISTEN. AS AM I AND SO I'M
VERY LET. GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE
TO INTRODUCE WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL THOSE WILL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW FEW. OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS FOR
TRADITIONALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- AND WITH US ARE
TIM RAINY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. CHRIS HANNAN
OF THE LA AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES AND BUYS
CHANNEL CHANCER XINYU OUR
SENIOR WEBER. OTHER CHANCES
OFFICE COMMITTEE COLLEGES I
EACH COUNCIL HAVE ABOUT EIGHT
MINUTES TO SPEAK IN OUR MIND
EVERYONE HERE THAT THIS IS ALL
BEING LIVE STREAMED AND
DOCUMENTED AND OFTEN TIMES TO
GREAT RESOURCE. ARE NOT JUST
FOR US BUT OUR STAFFS AS WELL
AS OTHERS THAT ARE IN THIS
SPACE SO- YOUR YOUR YOUR ABOVE
COMMENTS IN YOUR INSIDE IS VERY
VALUABLE WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU AND SO- MISTER RANEY
LIKE TO KICK IT OFF. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN CHOLERA MY- YOUR- IT
IS FOR THE. HELLO THE SWITCH ON
THE YEAH WHICH WAY TOO
COMPLICATED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I TEAM RAINY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
I'LL TRY TO MAKE MY COMMENTS-
BRIEF BECAUSE THEY'RE A LOT OF
MUCH SMARTER PEOPLE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THE WORK FOR
SYSTEM- AS FOLKS KNOW IS
REACHING COMPLEX- ITS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S IN THE JOB
CENTERS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SCHOOLS- CORRECTIONS PROGRAMS.
THAT HELP PEOPLE REENTER-
SOCIETY IN THE ECONOMY OF THE
TRAINING AND EDUCATION. THE
STATE FEDERAL INVESTMENT IN ALL
OF THAT SYSTEM IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA IS APPROXIMATELY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY- SO
IT'S NOTHING TO SHAKE A STICK
AT IT'S PRETTY. IT'S PRETTY
GENEROUS IN SOME SENSE- BUT
THERE GAPS IN IN IN BIG WAYS
I'LL TALK ABOUT IN A SECOND.
WOULD YOU ADD TO THAT STATE AND
FEDERALLY FUNDED SYSTEM MEAN
BASE ORGANIZATIONS WHICH ARE
THE BACKBONE IN MANY WAYS FOR
THE WORK FOR SYSTEM IN THE
STATE. OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS- BUT
ALSO THE INVESTMENTS IN
EMPLOYERS MAKE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS WHERE- THE
CONTRIBUTION FROM PLAYERS IS
GREAT BUT IN MANY CASES-
WORKERS INVEST IN THOSE AS WELL.
THE WAY WE GET OUR ARMS AROUND
THIS BIG SYSTEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IS STATE PLANNING
THE STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD PUTS TOGETHER A PLAN
EVERY FOUR YEARS- IT'S GOT A
BIG VISION- BUT IT'S REALLY.
FOCUSED ON- NEEDING TOGETHER
AND ALIGNING THIS WORK FOR
SYSTEM TO GET SCALE AN IMPACT
AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO SERVICES-
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY- AND
JUST BASICALLY MAKE A WORK FOR
SYSTEM THAT WORKS. FOR WORKERS
AND PEOPLE LOOKING AND
COMPANIES LOOKING FOR TALENT.
THE LED BY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S FOR THE
MOST PART THE STATE PLANNING IS
DONE BY THE STATE BOARD BUT AT
THE LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVELS.
OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
ARE DOING THE HARD WORK OF
ALIGNING- THIS BROAD WORK FOR
SYSTEM AROUND A COMMON AGENDA
ACROSS THE STATE. I THINK WORK
FOR SPORTS TEND TO GET A LOT OF
FLACK YESTERDAY. WE WERE IN
RIVERSIDE- FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR COMMISSION I THINK SOMEBODY.
TALKED ABOUT WORKFORCE BOARDS
AS CARTELS. I DON'T QUITE AGREE
I THINK THERE- THEY'RE DOING A
LOT OF IMPRESSIVE WORK AROUND
THE STATE- THEY DON'T GET A LOT
OF CREDIT FOR THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF CHANGE HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA WITH LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD SO I ACTUALLY
THINK THEY'RE THE BEST IN THE
NATION- THE GAPS THERE ARE
STILL MANY- AND AGAIN
REFLECTING ON YESTERDAY'S
FUTURE WORK COMMISSION MEETING
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS- INCREDIBLY
SMART- AND INDEED THE WASN'T
SERVICE WENT REALLY DEEP ON ON.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUES TO
THE STATE AND PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA- GOVERNOR GRAN
HOME TALKED ABOUT A MOTHER IN
GEORGIA TRYING TO RAISE A
DAUGHTER ON NINE DOLLARS AN
HOUR MOST POOR PEOPLE ACTUALLY
WORK THERE TWO MILLION WORKING
POOR PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALONE. THEY DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY TO ATTEND
TRAINING OR SIT THROUGH A
SEMESTER OF COURSES AND
COMMUNICATE WHICH BECAUSE
YOU'RE BUSY SUPPORTING THEIR
FAMILY. THEY NEED. INCOME WHILE
THEY'RE DOING TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ARE THE
BEST MODEL FOR THIS BUT NOT
EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WE
HAVEN'T BUILT A PARTNERSHIP-
SUBSTANTIALLY OUTSIDE OF THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. SO PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE THERE. NEED TO HAVE INCOME
WHILE THEY'RE IN TRAINING TO
SUPPORT THEM- THERE. ALSO OR IN
ADDITION LEAVE TIME WHILE
YOU'RE AT WORK TO GET THAT KIND
OF TRAINING IS CRUCIAL. ANOTHER
ONE AGAIN- FOCUSES YESTERDAY-
IS JOB QUALITY. THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH QUALITY JOBS IN OUR
ECONOMY FOR EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS
A GOOD JOB- AND THE WAY WE
DEFINE THIS IT WAS TO FIND
YESTERDAY I THINK IT. A FEW
TIMES INCLUDES ALL THE THINGS
YOU'D IMAGINE JOB QUALITY
SHOULD INCLUDE GOOD WAGES OF
COURSE BENEFITS- THEY'RE PAID
FOR BY EMPLOYERS FOR THE MOST
PART- PREDICTABLE WORK
SCHEDULES SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS. SKILLS TRAINING AND
MOBILITY. AND MANY FOR HER
VOICE. AND COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY MANY OF THOSE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHO ARE COMMITTED
TO THOSE PRINCIPLES WE CALL
HIGH ROAD- JUST A COUPLE MORE
POINTS ON- ON JOB QUALITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. A
GALLUP SURVEY RECENTLY FOUND
THAT TWENTY THREE PERCENT. OF
CALIFORNIANS SAY THERE ARE THEY
ARE AND QUOTE UNQUOTE BAD JOBS.
OUR AND ONE IN FIVE WORKERS. IN
CALIFORNIA WHO MAKE LESS THAN
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR. HAVE
AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE OR A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. BIG
CHALLENGES IN THE STATE AND THE
THIRD ONE. I PICKED UP FROM
YESTERDAY THERE'S A FOCUS ON
ECONOMIC. AND LABOR MARKET
CHANGE DRIVEN BY TECHNOLOGY
AUTOMATION IN THE IMPERATIVES
OF ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE IN
MITIGATING CLIMATE CHANGE- IF
WE DON'T ADDRESS TODAY'S
INEQUALITIES HOWEVER. WE BAKE
THOSE SAME INEQUITIES IN OUR
CURRENT LABOR MARKET INTO THE
FUTURE WORK. WE'VE GOT TO THIS
POINT OF GROSS INCOME
INEQUALITY AND WEALTH
INEQUALITY NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT AROUND THIS THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE GENERATIONS OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LOCKED OUT OF
A SHARE PROSPERITY- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS NOT GOING TO FIX
EVERYTHING WAS BROKEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT I THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD ATTEND THE
FUTURE WORK. MEETINGS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF COLOR IS ON THAT
MISSION- AND MADE SOME OF THE
BEST COMMENTS YESTERDAY AND I
DON'T SEE THAT JUST BECAUSE
HE'S IN THE ROOM- BECAUSE
ACTUALLY TRUE AND IS ON FILM SO
YOU CAN LOOK AT THAT FOR
YOURSELF- I THINK A LOT OF
THIS. WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IS A BIT OUTSIDE OF THE
REALM OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ITS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IT'S
ENFORCING LABOR LAW- IT'S CRAZY
POLICIES AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
THE LOCAL LEVEL CYNOSURE JOB
QUALITY. OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DOES HAVE A ROLE AT
THE STATE BOARD OUR BIG IDEA IS
THE BILL THE HIGHROAD ECONOMY
DEFINED BY QUALITY JOBS EQUITY
JUSTICE IN CLIMATE BILLION SEE
THIS IS THE GUIDING WORK OF THE
STATE- IT'S THE PRINCIPLE
THAT'S THAT'S- BEHIND CREATING
A NEW FUTURE WORK DEPARTMENT OF
CITY CALIFORNIA THAT'S GONNA
LINE. SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
INSTRUMENTAL WALKING THE
TALKING. SAME WAY WE WANT TO
ALIGN THE SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
THE REGIONAL LOCAL LEVELS TO
GET THAT SCALING IMPACT. I
THINK ALSO THIS IS WHERE
WORKFORCE IN DEVELOPMENT REALLY
COME TOGETHER THE OVERLAP IN IN
A ROW IN THE RIGHT WAY WE START
WITH THE BEST JOBS IN INDUSTRY
SECTORS THAT ARE DRIVING
EMPLOYMENT WE SUPPORT COMPANIES
AND EMPLOYERS THAT CARE ABOUT
SKILLS TRAINING AND MOBILITY
AND VALUE WORKER VOICE- THESE
COMPANIES TREAT THEIR WORKERS
NOT AS COSTS BUT IS ASSETS THAT
THE INVEST IN WE CALL THESE
HIERO COMPANIES. ADDITIONALLY
WE CREATE ACCESS TO THOSE JOBS
FOR PEOPLE WHO MOST NEED. GOOD
JOBS BY LINING THE WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS AND CONNECTING
PATHWAYS. TO JOBS FOR PEOPLE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SOMETHING A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM IS VERY GOOD
AT REMOVING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT DOING EQUITY WORK
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS INSURE
THAT WE'RE BUILDING BRIDGES. TO
COMPANIES THAT ACTUALLY OFFER
THE BEST JOBS AND THEN
SUPPORTING THOSE COMPANIES SO
THERE MOST COMPETITIVE AND THEY
GROW IN THE STATE. AND CREATE
NEW JOBS. IT TURNS OUT THAT
ECONOMIC JUSTICE- IS GOOD
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. QUALITY
JOBS PRIME THE PUMP THEY PUT
DOLLARS IN THE POCKETS OF
PEOPLE WHO LIVE WORK AND
SPENDING THEIR COMMUNITIES. ARE
IT ALSO PAYS DIVIDENDS IN THE
LONG TERM GOOD JOBS. AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY- PAY OFF
EXPONENTIALLY BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES THAT FACT THAT PEOPLE
BEEN LOCKED OUT COMMITTEES BEEN
LOCKED OUT OF PROSPERITY FOR
GENERATIONS. IF WE BUILD STRONG
FAMILIES WITH GOOD QUALITY JOBS
JOBS TODAY. IT PAYS OFF IN THE
FUTURE WE- WERE IN FRESNO LAST
WEEK FOR THE REGION'S RISE
TOGETHER EVENT- FROM THE
ECONOMIC SUMMIT WAS VERY GOOD
EVENT. BEFORE THAT HAPPENED
THAT EVENT TOOK PLACE WE WERE
TALKING TO A GROUP OF BUILDING
TRADES UNIONS AND LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS ABOUT HIRING
CONSTRUCTION CREWS WORK- AND
THEIR- WAS IN MAN NAMED JOHN
GOMEZ. WHO GOT INTO
CONSTRUCTION THROUGH THE MULTI
CRAFT HIERO CONSTRUCTION
TRAINING PROGRAM IN FRESNO. HE
DESCRIBED IT HE WAS IN AND OUT
OF SCHOOL A YOUNG MAN IN AND
OUT OF PRISON. HE'S NOW A UNION
PLUMBER. HE SAID WHEN HE COMES
HOME FROM WORK HIS SON PUTS HIS
BOOTS ON. AND PUTS HIS HARD HAT
ON AND SAYS I WANT TO BE LIKE
THAT- JOHN WAS FILLED WITH
PRIDE WHEN HE DESCRIBED AS- A
YOU COULD SEE HIS FACE YOU
COULD SEE IT IN HIS BODY
LANGUAGE- HE'S NOT A COST TO
THIS COMMUNITY. HE'S AN ASSET
TO HIS COMMUNITY. HE MADE A
BETTER LIFE FOR HIS FAMILY.
THEN HE HAD. AND HIS KIDS ARE
MAKING IT. A BETTER LIFE WILL
MAKE A BETTER LIFE FROM THEIR
FAMILY- SO IT PAYS OFF
EXPONENTIALLY. OVER THE LONG
TERM SO WE CAN START TO
CORRECT. THE INEQUITIES OF THE
PAST. BY DEFINING A FUTURE WORK
THAT'S BASED ON DIGNITY. I
WOULD ALSO WANT TO SAY. JUST
REAL QUICK TO SET UP THE HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AND HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP THAT YOU
CAN HEAR MORE ABOUT- WE HAVE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- AT
THE STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD- OVER FIVE YEARS AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS IN GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDING TO EXPAND HI
RECONSTRUCTION CREWS IN THE
STATE- THESE ARE PARTNERSHIP
THE BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
TO GET ACCESS TO STATE APPROVED
PARTNERSHIP. TO PEOPLE IN
POPULATIONS COMMITTEES WHO HAVE
BEEN WHO HAVEN'T HAD THAT
ACCESS STATE WOULD
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. USING
THE MOST CRAFT OR CURRICULUM-
THIS IS CREATING CITY IN THE
TREES THAT WE EVER SEEN BEFORE
THAT CHRIS WITH MORE ABOUT. ONE
THING IS REALLY IMPORTANT YOU
MAKING THOSE PROGRAMS WORK IS
NOT PUSHING PEOPLE AND LABOR
MARKETS TO FINISH. BUT SPENDING
THIS WEEK. JOBS SO USING HUMAN
WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS THEIR
SURPRISE. THAT IT PULLED PEOPLE
OUT OF OUR PRE CONSTRUCTION
TRAINING PROGRAMS INTO SOME OF
THE BEST JOB THAT YOU CAN
POSSIBLY HAVE THAT DON'T
REQUIRE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE. HI
RETRAINING PARTNERSHIPS ARE
SIMILAR BUT THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE NOT XIN- INTO A SECTOR
OF FOLK. COMPANIES ON IT I
THINK PATHWAYS TO THE JOB
CONNIE BUILT THESE IN EIGHT
INDUSTRY SECTORS IN THE. STATE
THE DEMONSTRATION WORK OF THE
LAST SIX YEARS AND WE'RE- GAS
REDUCTION MILLION DOLLARS OVER.
AND I'LL- THANK YOU MY THE AND
YOU'RE DOING. THURMOND THANK
YOU FOR THE BACKGROUND ON THE
AND THEN THERE WILL BE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS. SUGGESTED THAT WE GO.
THE TIME FOR. A SEPARATE ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT WELL I'M UP.
THIS IS A. GOOD THING HONORABLE
CHAIR AUDIBLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THE BUILDING TRADES ON THE
PANEL THIS MORNING. OUR
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL IS LOS.
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY IS
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE
REPRESENT FORTY EIGHT. WHO THE
FINAL IN THE OPTION IT. THEY
REPRESENT A HUNTER AND HE
THOUGHT. THE FOUGHT FOR ALL THE
WAY WEEK WE GOT A BIG THE FIVE.
OUT OF A SHIP. PROGRAMS.
TRAINING CENTER LOCAL CENTERS.
WE GET INTO THE PRESSURE
PROGRAM WE GO TO WORK TURN ON.
FROM. A GOOD WAGE MOST OF THE
PROGRAMS ARE STARTING AROUND
TWENTY DOLLARS AN HOUR WITH
FULL BENEFITS HEALTH CARE FOR
OUR OUR IS IT AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE KEY TO. GETTING
INTO ONE OF THE PROGRAMS AS
BEING THE BEST A COMPACT TO
TEND TO WE'VE HAD. VERY GOOD
LUCK IN THE ANDERSON ORANGE
COUNTY. BROWN BEEN. SEVEN YEARS
SET UP PARTNERSHIPS WITH.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE OVER
TWENTY PARTNERSHIPS TODAY. AND
WE HAVE BEEN DELIVER IT TO SET
UP SHIP SO. A LOT ANGELES AND
INTO THE CAN OF ORANGE SO THAT
THE Q. HAVE US SO THAT
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH HAS ACCESS
SO THAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT
WE MAY HAVE NOT. DONE THE BEST
JOB REACHING IN THE PAST. WE
HAVE SEARCHED FOR SOME
COMMUNITIES WERE WERE WORKING
WE HAVE. COMMENTS WITH CALLS
FOR CONTRACTORS WE SET UP THESE
PROGRAMS THE- THE COMMUNITY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE GOOD
CAREERS WERE NOT ALL I'M JUST
ANY CAREER. WHERE ARE THE SAME
CAREER THAT. I START AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM TWENTY
FOUR YEARS AGO WERE OFFERING
THE SAME TO THE COMMUNITY BUT
OUR CLASS CLASSES LOOK LIKE OUR
PRESSURE BRAIN IS PROGRAMS THEY
LOOK LIKE ENERGY. WE HAVE A
PROGRAM IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES IT
REPRESENTS THE COMMUNITY IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES IF WE HAVE A
PROGRAM IN NORTHERN LA COUNTY
LOCATED IN EITHER LANCASTER
PALM BILL IT REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNITY IT LOOKS LIKE THE
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY. IN STATE PRISON. THEY
REPRESENT THE POPULATION IN IN
THE IN THE PRISON WE DO OUR
VERY BEST TO PREPARE THE
INDIVIDUAL TO BE COMPETITIVE TO
GET INTO THE APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING PROGRAM NOT ONLY
COMPETITIVE TO GET IN BUT TO
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING SO WE
TAKE TIME INTRODUCED THEM TO
THE THANKS WE DON'T JUST USE
THEM TO ONE TRADE OR WE THINK
IT WOULD BE WIENER. ALL THE
TRADES SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE A
DECISION ON THEIR OWN ON WHERE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO GO WHERE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO APPLY. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SENIORITY IN THE
TRADES WE DO OUR BEST TO WORK
OURSELVES OUT OF A JOB EVERY
DAY AND THERE'S TOUGH DAYS IT'S
STILL A TOUGH WAY TO MAKE A
LIVING. YOU HAVE TO REALLY WANT
TO BE THERE TO DO GOOD SO WE
INTRODUCED THE STUDENTS TO ALL
THE TRADES. WE GIVE THEM IN FOR
WILL LET THEM MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION AND WE HELP SUPPORT
THEM SO AFTER INTRODUCED THEM
TO ALL THE TRADES WE TAKE THEM
ON TOURS OF DIFFERENT
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
CENTERS. SO THAT THEY GET A
CHANCE TO. RELATE WITH
APPRENTICES IN THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS NOT JUST A PROGRAM FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE IT'S NOT A PROGRAM
FOR. CERTAIN GENDERS- THIS THE
PROGRAM FOR EVERYBODY AND WE
WANT TO BRING THE STUDENTS OUT
TO APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
CENTER SO THEY HAVE A CHANCE.
TO SEE WHAT OUR PREMISE LOOKS
LIKE TO SEE WHAT AYE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING PROGRAM
LOOKS LIKE. FIRST HAND. WE GIVE
THEM THE- THE WE RUN THROUGH
THE TENER OSHA SO THAT SAFETY
IS BUILT INTO THE CULTURE FROM
THE FIRST DAY. SAFETY IS BUILT
IN. IT'S STILL A DANGEROUS.
PLACE IT'S A DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE TO WORK
SAFE IN A DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT. WE DO
CONSTRUCTION- APPLIED
MATHEMATICS THERE'S MATH
INVOLVED IN ALMOST OUT OF EVERY
ELEMENT OF CONSTRUCTION EVEN IF
WE DON'T THINK IT'S MATH
THERE'S MATH INVOLVED WE'RE
GONNA INTRODUCE THEM TO THE
TOOLS IN THE MATERIALS OF THE
TRADES. BLUEPRINT READING
THEY'RE GONNA LEARN MORE ABOUT
BLUEPRINTS WHEN THEY GET INTO
APPRENTICESHIP. BUT THEY NEED
TO BE COMFORTABLE AND CONFIDENT
ONCE THEY GET INTO
APPRENTICESHIP TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL THEY NEED TO LEARN
ABOUT THE HERITAGE OF AMERICAN
WORKER. DIVERSITY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY GREEN
CONSTRUCTION FINANCIAL LITERACY.
WE'VE SET UP THEIR SHIPS. WITH
THE. SET UP A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION SOME HAVE PROVED
NOT TO BE A ARE NOT TO BE
DIFFICULT IF WERE DELIBERATE
WERE DELIBERATE FOR FORMAL
INCARCERATED WERE DELIBERATE TO
INVOLVE. PARTNERS THAT CAN HELP
REDUCE ALL. ISSUES HELP PEOPLE
GROW AND THEN SUPPORT PEOPLE
ARE. FOR MY CAR SERRATED THE
SECOND IS A PROGRAM THAT'S MADE
UP OF 49% WITH A HISTORY OF-
INVOLVEMENT IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THEY'RE GETTING
INTO CAREERS CARTING AROUND
TWENTY DOLLARS ARE WHEN THEY
FINISH THEY HAVE TOTAL WHERE
THEY ARE. FROM THE FORTY DOLLAR
AN HOUR RANGE. OVER THE DOLLARS
NOW. THEY HAVE A CHANCE. STYLE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
ORANGE COUNTY. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE SEE IN WAS- WAS
A BEAR THERE WAS NOT
NECESSARILY THE INDIVIDUAL BUT
IN SETTING UP THESE PARTNERS
MOST OF MY- FUNDED. THERE'S UP.
WHEN THE COURTS. I FOR THE NEXT
GRANT. THEY DON'T ALWAYS GET
THE NEXT GRANT WE WANTED TO
TAKE A BIGGER. OUR PARTNER
SWITCHED ON PROFIT SO THAT
COULD BE HELPFUL IN GOING AFTER
SECURE AND STABLE FUNDING FOR
AGES. WE SET UP AND PROFIT WE
HAVE. OTHER WITHOUT WARNING AND
AS OF YESTERDAY WE JUST HIRED A
CASE MANAGER TO WORK WITH ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS HAVE THE BEST CASE
MANAGERS ANYWAY. BRILLIANT YEAH.
ALL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS HAVE
QUALITY CASE MANAGEMENT QUALITY.
THANK YOU. WORKING PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY HERE- AND
UP NEXT ANY. THE CHANCES OFFICE
SECURITY COLLEGES. GOOD THING
CHECK OUR. STATION HERE TO TALK
ABOUT WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. THE
VICE. A PERSON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
ALL CALIFORNIANS ME COLLEGES.
THE PROGRAMS OF FALLEN DIVISION.
INCLUDES THE STRONG FORCE KATO
STRONG WITH FORCE I'LL MAKE A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ADULT
EDUCATION. OTHERS TODAY THOUGH
I WOULD LIKE TO- HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF ALL PROGRAMS I THINK
THAT ARE VERY RELEVANT TO OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY AND THAT'S
THE CALIFORNIA DAHLE EDGY
PROGRAM. AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUNISHED. THE ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM IS AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
THAT SUPPORTS AND SERVES THE
LOW INCOME THE NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING AN UNEMPLOYED IN JOEL.
THOSE WITHOUT A HIGH PALOMA AN
ILLITERATE ADULTS EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND OLDER. THE PROGRAM
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY IN
PATHWAYS IN THE. AND FOR THE
HONORABLE OUR POPULATIONS. WITH
THE FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
ADULTS WITHOUT A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA. AN ADULT EDUCATION
OFFERS A VIABLE OPTION TO GAIN
CATION. BE ABLE TO OTHER YOUR
AND FEEL I'M PREPARED TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. AND THE CURRENT ADULT
EDUCATION SYSTEM SERVES OVER
ONE MILLION ADULTS THROUGH
PROGRAMS RUN BY K. TWELVE
PROVIDERS COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
DOES. TO IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS CASSIDY OF THE
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM AND
FINING CREDIT AND CREDIT
PATHWAYS TO HELP ADULTS UP
SKILL IN ACCESS FINANCIAL AID
AND OTHER SUPPORT ALONG THE WAY
YOU CAN HE- WITH FIVE POINT
MILLION ADULTS WITHOUT HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND US ONLY BE
ABLE TO CURRENTLY SERVE A
MILLION. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA. LEGISLATORS A PAST
AB ONE OH FOUR WHICH LED TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE ADULT
EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT. I'M FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION. THE CHANCES
ARE OFFICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND THE
SUPREME OF PUB STRUCK XIN. THIS
BILL. ONE REGIONAL CONSORTIA
EACH COMPRISE OF SEGMENTAL
REPRESENTATION TO DEVELOP THE
ADULT EDUCATION GENERAL PLANS.
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
PROVIDE A LOT OF. IMPROVED
PROGRAMMATIC OUTCOMES. SERVE
THE ADULT POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN NEED OF SKILLS
AND TRAINING TO SAID Q. OF THE
MIDDLE SKILLED SHOPS. PROVIDERS
WHO RECEIVE FUNDING LOOSE.
DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION OTHER SCHOOLS AND
STATE PROGRAMS. THERE'S
ACTUALLY BEEN A FATHER
CONSISTENT LEVELS WITHOUT.
ASIAN PROGRAMS AND FIVE.
MINUTES ACTUALLY PRETTY SICK.
AND THE SYSTEM CURRENTLY IS
WORKING THROUGH SOME. I. YOU
KNOW- TIME COMPETITION THAT HAS
CREATE BEEN CREATED THE SYSTEM
SILOS AND ALSO WORKING ON FINAL
A LOT EIGHT A CURRICULUM
SPECIFICALLY ADDING THE BIGGEST
PIECE THAT IS THE DATA. THAT
WHICH YOU ARE IN PLACE THAT'S
GOING TO CREATE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO LOOK AT DATA
THAT WILL HELP US BETTER DIRECT
INVESTMENTS JUST GIVE YOU SOME.
I ABOUT THE A POPULATION THAT'S
BEING SERVED 40% 40% ENGLISH
THE OWNERS 24% ABOUT ELEVEN
OFFER AND A CULT HAVE ACTUAL
BARRIERS AND WE HAVE- YOU KNOW
IT SINGLE DIGIT PERCENTAGE WITH
LOW LITERACY SINGLE PARENTS
LONG TERM UNEMPLOYED- WE HAVE
JUST A DISABLED EX OFFENDERS
DISPLAYS HOME WORKERS THE
HOMELESS CEDAR SEASONAL
FARMWORKERS MIGRANT WORKERS TO
USE AND TENNIS RECIPIENTS. OF
ALL BEINGS IDEA DAHLE AT
PROGRAM. JEAN GEARS WANNA TALK
A LOT ABOUT
. TO SHIP PROGRAMS
MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS. EIGHT
IT'S FOR PARTNERSHIPS AND-
ESPECIALLY THE BUILDING TRADE
JOBS THAT PROVIDE VERY WELL
PAYING- CAREERS FOR A FOR
INDIVIDUALS. OUR INVESTMENT IN
IN THE FIFTEEN MILLION A LOT OF
IT HAS BEEN GOING INTO- TRYING
TO CREATE A PARTNERSHIP OR ON
AND LEARN PROGRAMS IN
NONTRADITIONAL INDUSTRY SUCH AS
HEALTHCARE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY WE ARE EXPLORING THE
UP APPLICATION OF EARN AND
LEARN PROGRAM FOR TEACHER
PREPARATION I THINK THAT'S A
LOT OF PROMISE THERE- THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. BECAUSE
THEY PROVIDE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES ESPECIALLY FOR
THE FORMALLY INCARCERATED-
EMANCIPATED FOSTER YOUTH
INDIVIDUALS FACING MENTAL
SUBSTANCE ABUSE- IN PARTICULAR
AS AN EXAMPLE WE DO HAVE A
CULINARY APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
THAT- THAT THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE NONPROFIT KITCHENS
FOR GOOD AND GROSSMONT UNION
HIGH SCHOOL ADULT ED PROGRAM.
AND IT BRAIDS PHILANTHROPY
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS CPAP
ANOTHER FUNDING FOR
SUSTAINABILITY AND SERVES- VERY
DIVERSE POPULATION 28% AFRICAN
AMERICAN 34% HISPANIC- 28%
NATIVE ALASKAN AT PRODUCING
ABOUT TO OVER TWO HUNDRED
APPRENTICES AND THE OTHER THING
I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM IS IT'S 61% FEMALE. SO
THE RIGHT YOU SEE THE
REPRESENTATION IS PRETTY
DIAPERS. IN TERMS OF
PRIORITIZING INITIATIVES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS- AREAS FOR
CONSIDERATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE- WOULD BE SUPPORTING
MORE APPRENTICESHIP AND EARN A
LOAN PROGRAMS I THINK-
EMPLOYERS NEED TO BE ENCOURAGED
TO PARTNER WITH ORGANIZATIONS
WITH COLLEGES THE DESIGN THESE
PROGRAMS WE CAN'T DO THESE
WITHOUT EMPLOYER PARTNERSHIPS-
MOST OF OUR STUDENTS. AND ADULT
LEARNERS ARE NOT ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL FULL TIME- SO THE
SCHEDULING AND FLEXIBILITY OF
PROGRAMS ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
PARTICULARLY I WOULD WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT- SHORT TERM WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS WE HAVE OF
VERY SMALL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT UNITS THROUGHOUT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT ARE VERY
RESPONSIVE VERY NIMBLE AND GOOD
PARTNERS WITH INDUSTRY AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO STAND UP OUR
TRAINING VERY QUICKLY TO
ADDRESS THE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
NEEDS. TO FOCUS ON SHOP TURN
SHORT TERM TRAINING FOR GOOD
CAREERS. THE CHALLENGE FOR
THESE PROGRAMS ARE THERE NOT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FALL ON THE
CREDIT BEARING SIDE THEY'RE NOT
WELL FUNDED- CONTRACT THAT
EDUCATION IS AN EXAMPLE AND
THERE HAS NOT BEEN AND
INVESTMENT INTO THAT PARTICULAR
SIDE OF THE SYSTEM. TO DO A
COMPREHENSIVE DATA COLLECTION
SYSTEMS STATEWIDE TO CAPTURE
THE OUTCOMES- BUT A LOT OF
THESE PROGRAMS DO PRODUCE JOB
PLACEMENTS AND THEY PUT PEOPLE
INTO CAREERS AND THEY ARE A
VERY GOOD AVENUE IN. IN
DEVELOPING LIFELONG LEARNING IN
AN ENTRY INTO EDUCATION THAT
CAN EVENTUALLY LEAD TO CREDIT
BEARING PROGRAMS AND NON CREDIT
PROGRAMS. AND ANOTHER AREA FOR
CONSIDERATION IS THE THERE ARE
JOBS THAT ARE IN HIGH DEMAND
OUT THERE THAT NOT THEY'RE NOT
PARTICULARLY FOCUS ON BECAUSE
OF THE PAY WAGE SO FOR EXAMPLE
THE HOME ON HEALTH AIDE-
THERE'S A HUGE DEMAND WE ARE
ASKED TO DO A LOT OF TRAINING.
THE CONCERN HAS BEEN AROUND THE
WAGES AND SO DO YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU FIND CAREER PATHWAYS INTO
OTHER HIGHER PAYING WAGES FROM
THESE KINDS OF JOBS WHICH ARE
IN DEMAND- DIMENSION- ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT KEY PART
THAT I THINK COULD ME COLLEGES
REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON. IT
DOES TWO THINGS A CREE
INNOVATION IN PROGRAMS IT
CREATES MORE INNOVATION AND A
DIFFERENT MINDSET FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. OPERATIONS AT
ADMINISTRATION AND ALSO
PROVIDES A LOT OF VERY GOOD
EMPLOYABILITY SKILLS FOR
STUDENTS WHEN WE TEACH THEM
THAT ON TO BRING MINDSET
ESPECIALLY IN THE RURAL
COMMUNITY I THINK THE
IMPORTANCE OF BEING FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL BEING ABLE TO CREATE
A JOB FOR THEMSELVES RATHER
THAN TAKE A JOB. IS
PARTICULARLY. IMPORTANT.
FINALLY I JUST WANNA MENTION
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
GOING ON IN A SYSTEMS A LINEMAN
TRYING TO ALIGN AND LOOK AT ALL
OF THE EXISTING INVESTMENT
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN MADE. A
PART OF OUR CHALLENGES IS- A
LOT OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE-
DEVELOP AND OPERATE IN SILOS
BECAUSE OF JUST THE WAY. I
THINK THAT LEGISLATION ON
FUNDING IS ENACTED AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW BEST
TO MAXIMIZE LEVERAGE AND
COLLABORATE ACROSS THE
PROGRAMS. SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME THINGS THAT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THANK YOU. SO MUCH A
BASS CHANCELLOR WEBER AND IF PM
AND YOU OFFER SOME REALLY GOOD.
SUGGESTIONS OF THINGS THAT
COULD BE DONE IF I COULD BEFORE
I BRING IT BACK- TO MY
COLLEAGUES. EACH OF YOU-
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A- A
LIMITATION AND WE DO HAVE SOME
GREAT CHAMPIONS APPEAR ABOVE
HOW MUCH WE CAN DO A ONE TIME
IF YOU HAD TO PICK ONE THINGS
LIKE A THIRTY SECOND LIGHTING
AROUND ONE THING COULD BE
BUDGET. REGULATION OR
LEGISLATIVE ACT. WHAT WOULD YOU
SUGGEST WE DO TO HELP YOU IN
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING.
OKAY I WOULD SAY INVEST IN THE
SHORT TERM A WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND CONSISTENT FUNDING
LIKE WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH
CREDIT. OF BEARING PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE HAVE GOT TO BE
COMPETITIVE WITH THE FOR
PROFITS. AND THAT HELPS-
STUDENTS REDUCE THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN AS WELL AND THAT THAT.
THANK YOU. BUT I HAVE TO GO
AHEAD SO THIRTY SECONDS TO GO
HEAD TO. A THE FIRST IS- I TALK
ABOUT THE NEED FOR- SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE- THE THIS
WE DON'T HAVE SYSTEMATICALLY
THAT KIND OF A RESOURCE- A
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO. WHO
NEED SUPPORT IN GOING THROUGH
TRAINING PROGRAMS- WORK FOR
SPORTS HAVE A LITTLE COLLEGES
HAVE SOME- COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PROBABLY PROVIDE
THE MOST SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE WHO
MOST NEED ACCESS TO JOBS- BUT
WE NEED SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES
TO ALLOW PEOPLE. TO HAVE INCOME
WHILE THEY GO THROUGH THESE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
BE SUCCESSFUL THAT'S ONE OF THE
SECOND IS MORE ON THE JOB
QUALITY SITE I THINK THE STATE
COULD DO MORE. IN ATTACHING.
PRIORITIES ARE VALUES TO
DOLLARS THAT COME OUT FROM THE
STATE CONTRACTING AND
PROCUREMENT. THAT COULD HELP
DRIVE JOB QUALITY AROUND THE
STATE IF WE DID THAT A STATE
LEVEL. BUT ALSO THE LOCAL
MUSICAL LEVELS WE COULD REALLY
MOVE THE NEEDLE ON JOB QUALITY
IN THE STATE OF THE WAY YEAH
THEN I DID COME OUT YESTERDAY
DURING THE COMMISSION HEARING
NOTHING IT'S GOOD POINT FOR THE
FOR THE BILL. FOR THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OUR WORK. LET LIMIT
TO HOW MUCH WE CAN HELP AND HOW
MUCH OPPORTUNITY THERE IS HOW
MUCH WORK OPPORTUNITY AND NOT
JUST WORK OPPORTUNITY RANDOM WE
NEED- A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
TO BUT BECAUSE IT'S PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS THAT ARE EMPLOYING
OUR MEMBERS WE NEED A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT THAT SETS
HIRING GOALS. TO FORWARD
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FOR
LOCAL RESIDENTS SO WHEN THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY IN A PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECT TO SUPPORT OUR
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT-
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE AGREEMENT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE OUR BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY. WIN WIN ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE TIM'S TOO
AND THERE I MUST MAKE A SECOND
ONE IF YOU COULD GIVE THE FUNDS
WE HAVE TO HAVE REGULATION BUT
IF THE FUNDS CAN HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF FLEXIBILITY. TO TAILOR
TO THE PROGRAM NOT EVERY
INDIVIDUALS THE SAME YOU COULD
HAVE SOMEONE TAKING ONE OF OUR
CLASSES AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THAT THE CLASSES GRAY. CHECK
THE TOWARDS THE AND- GREAT
INSTRUCTOR GREAT SUPPORT GREAT
OPPORTUNITY SOMEONE DOES VERY
WELL FOR SOMEBODY THAT- MAYBE
WENT THROUGH THE FOSTER YOUTH
SYSTEM. MAYBE SOMEBODY THAT
JUST GOT OUT OF PRISON
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AS REQUIRED
SOME INDIVIDUALS A STIPEND
COULD REALLY HELP THEM STAY IN
THE TRAINING PROGRAM A CASE
MANAGER TO HAVE ENCOURAGEMENT
TO STAY IN THE TRAINING
PROGRAM. ONCE THEY GET INTO THE
NEXT LEVEL OF TRAINING WE NEED
TO STILL HAVE CASE MANAGEMENT
INTERACTION FOR THE
ENCOURAGEMENT SO NOT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IS THE SAME OR HAS
THE SAME NEEDS SO ALLOWING US
TO HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THE
WORK FORCE DOLLARS TO HELP US
SUPPORT THOSE. I REALLY LIKE TO
VERY SPECIFIC GAS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE PURPOSE THE
SIMPLE HEARINGS ARE WE HAVE
MEMBERS UP HERE THEIR CHAMPIONS
THAT THAT WOULD BRING FOR
LEGISLATION WILL CERTAINLY. PUT
TOGETHER THE DIFFERENT
SUGGESTIONS AND AN OFFER THEM
UP AS POTENTIAL EVEN
LEGISLATION INTO THE NEXT YEAR
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT- MY
COLLEAGUES. PLEASE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE FOR. SO. AREA I AM SO
THANK YOU FOR COMING FOR THE
BUILDING TRADES BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS WHAT I USE IS THE MODEL
AND I HAVE TO REMIND MYSELF
THAT IT'S A CONSTANT BATTLE TO
BE THE MODEL FOR- WORKERS WHO
MAYBE DON'T HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE BUT CAN HAVE- A MIDDLE
CLASS OR UPPER MIDDLE CLASS
JOB- WE HAVE TO CONTINUE THAT
BUT THE REASON I POINT THAT OUT
AND MY QUESTION IS TO MR RAINY.
WE'VE BEEN AT THE STATE WE JUST
PASSED A BILL TO ALLOW-
ORGANIZING A CHILD CARE. AND A
PART OF THE I THINK
INTENTIONALITY THAT SOME OF US
ONE OUT OF THAT REALLY IS
MODELED AFTER THE TRADES YOU
KNOW A HUNDRED YEARS AGO A
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS AGO
SOMEBODY DECIDED. THE BUILDING
TRADES JOBS WE CAN BE GOOD JOBS
AND INCLUDED TRAINING IN OSHA
STANDARDS AND- PREVAILING WAGE
AND- DAVIS BACON AND YOU KNOW
WE COULD GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
AND THEN ULTIMATELY THE GOAL OF
P. LA. DO WE HAVE ANY PRO I IN
I FEEL LIKE WITH CHILD CARE FOR
US TO RAISE THE WAGES OF A JOB
BY THE WAY THAT CAN'T BE
OUTSOURCED THAT CAN'T BE
AUTOMATED- THAT DOES NOT
NECESSARILY REQUIRE. A COLLEGE
DEGREE IN SOME ASPECTS OF MY
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
BUT- DO WE HAVE TRAINING
PROGRAMS OUT THERE IN PLACE
THAT WILL HELP WITH THAT
COMPONENT TO ENSURE THE PEOPLE
SEE IT. AS A HIGH QUALITY JOBS
IN THAT WE CAN PUSH PEOPLE
TOWARDS A CAREER IN CHILD CARE
THE WAY WE HAVE. MAYBE MODELED
AFTER THE TRADES. THIS IS THANK
YOU THAT THAT'S A- THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION. THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS INVESTED
IN- OF A PARTNERSHIP WITH YES
YEAH YOU. DEVELOPING A CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS ON THE STATE-
FOUR ROUNDS. OF FUNDING FROM US
TO HELP DEVELOP- PROGRAM IN
PROFESSIONAL IS THAT WORKFORCE-
AND THEY'VE EVEN STARTED
DEVELOPING A PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM FOR CHILDCARE WORKERS-
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY WORK IN THE
STATE AND I SEE THAT IT. THE
POTENTIAL FOR X. SCALING THAT
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES OF THE
GOVERNOR OF THIS AND THE
LEGISLATURE- HAVE REAL
POTENTIAL NOT FOR PEOPLE- ONLY
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENT
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. WHICH IS
LARGELY WOMEN WOMEN IN
IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE-
PROFESSIONAL ISING INCREASE
THEIR WILL THEIR WAGES BUT ALSO
NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE.
TAKING GOOD JOBS- SO I SEE A
LOT OF POTENTIAL THERE. OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS OR SO. CHRIS
JUST TOOK A QUICK QUESTION. IS
WHAT PERCENTAGE I DON'T THINK
THIS IS WELL KNOWN PUBLICLY.
CENTER AGE OF THE COSTS IN THE
BUILDING TRADES APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE PRIVATE AND WHICH
ARE PUBLIC. THE FUNDS. SO FOR
THE BUILDING TRADES
APPRENTICESHIPS- THEY THEY
REALLY PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE
UNION AND ITS MEMBERS AND THE
CONTRACTORS WE HAVE OUR MODEL
IS A JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM AND IN OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS WE OF
BARGAINS- TRAPPING DOLLARS SO
MOST OF THE FUNDING IS ALL
PRIVATE AND IT WAS PAID FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE EMPLOYER- IN THE
BENEFIT OF THE MEMBERS- THERE
IS A SMALL AMOUNT THAT DOES
COME FROM THE STATE- BUT IT'S A
VERY SMALL AMOUNT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WE'RE INVESTING OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- PAID FOR BY THE
EMPLOYERS. ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS. A GREAT. AND TIM IF
YOU COULD IF THERE WERE
SPECIFIC YOU MENTIONED THE
ISSUE OF PROCUREMENT. ATTACHING
CHAU QUALITY TO PROCUREMENT
CAME UP- I HAD A BILL- WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE ON
WITH- ABOUT JUST GIVING US.
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO OUR DOLLARS. THAT GO TO
QUOTE UNQUOTE JOB CREATION- SO
I'M HOPING THAT THAT WILL GET
ALL THE WAY THROUGH AND SIGNED.
A JUST TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION FROM OUR STATE. AS
TO HOW MUCH OF. MONEY EVERY
TIME THERE'S A CONTRACT SIGNED
THAT HAS JOB CREATION AT THE
CENTER OF IT WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO KNOW IF THE EMPLOYER IF THE
COMPANY IS COMING THROUGH WITH
THAT. SUCH AS WHEN I DID IT
OCCUR TO A UP TO US ARE THERE
OTHER SPECIFIC IDEAS. AS
MENTIONED EITHER FUNDING OR
LEGISLATION. THAT HAVE COME UP.
I IN A COUPLE OF IT IT OF
EXAMPLES OF WHERE IT'S WORKED
IN SACRAMENTO- ON THE NEW STATE
BUILDINGS GOING UP DOWNTOWN- WE
SEE THE CRANES WE SEE THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF BOTH OF THOSE-
OUR INTER PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT BUT THERE ALSO IS
CHRIS DESCRIBED A SOCIAL
BENEFIT BUILT INTO THOSE
REPUBLIC A COMMITTEE WORKFORCE
AGREEMENT- THAT SOURCES NEW
APPRENTICES FROM THE PRE
CONSTRUCTION TRAINING PROGRAM-
IN SACRAMENTO IN A
COLLABORATION WITH. COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THE WORK
FORCE FOR THEIR AND THE LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL SO THAT
DIRECT PATHWAYS INTO THOSE
CONSTRUCTION DROPS FOR THE NEW
APPRENTICESHIPS LOTS OF OPENING
UP- I THINK THAT COULD BE AND
SHOULD BE EXPANDED ACROSS
ACROSS THE STATE SO WE STARTED
WITH THOSE TO STAY BUILDINGS IN
DOWNTOWN TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
COULD BE DONE A TO DEMONSTRATE
TO THE TO D. G. S. THAT IT
COULD BE DONE- WE'VE GOT SOME
TRUE BELIEVERS- THERE SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT- POSSIBLY EXPANDING
THAT. THAT THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL UP PUT OUT DOLLARS- FOR
FRESNO IN LOS ANGELES PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL DOLLARS TO DEVELOP
COMMUNITY- PLANNING AROUND HOW
THEY'RE GONNA INCREASED ACCESS
TO GOOD JOBS BILL GOOD JOBS
INCREASE ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS
AND WE WORKED WITH IS THE
STRATEGIC COUNCIL TO BUILD IN
THE SAME- VALUES AND
PRINCIPLES. US SO THAT THE JOBS
OF THE GREATER GOOD QUALITY
NUMBER ONE- AND THEN THERE'S A
EQUITY ANGLE IT'S VERY PRESENT
THERE THAT HELPING PEOPLE FROM
THE TO BEING. COMMITTEES AROUND
AS THOUGH. TO GET ACCESS TO
THOSE JOBS. WE'RE TALKING ALSO
WILL CLIMB AGENCIES IN
SACRAMENTO. THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. ARE THERE RESOURCES
BOARD IN OTHERS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN ATTACH SIMILAR PRINCIPLES
TO DOLLARS AND GO UP FROM THOSE
AGENCIES- BECAUSE IT'S A
PRETTY. BIG INVESTMENT THAT'S
GOING OUT AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO DO THINGS LIKE-
BUILD. NEW ZERO EMISSION BUSES
AND THE LIKE- SO I THINK THERE.
IS HUGE POTENTIAL ACROSS THE
BOARD IN SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU
OF I HAVE SEVERAL OF YOU
MENTIONED- THE IMPORTANCE OF
COLLABORATING- YOU KNOW FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO THE
BUILDING TRADE. APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS- WHAT CAN WE DO AS THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO HELP WITH
THOSE COLLABORATIONS AND TO
MAKE SURE. THAT YOU WORKING
TOGETHER- SO TO HAVE BEEN. OR
WHY I THINK IN THE END THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS- THE YOU'VE
ALREADY INTENTIONAL- WITH SOME
OF YOUR NEWER LEGISLATION AND
WHEN YOU'RE SUPPORTING GETTING
BACK TO- SENATOR THE CENTER'S
COMMENTS ON IF THERE'S
WORKFORCE DOLLARS ARE THOSE
WORK FIRST DOLLARS BEING SPENT
IN AN AREA WHERE THE RESULTING
IN GOOD JOBS. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS WRITTEN STANDARDS AND TO
THE DOLLARS THAT HE IF WE'RE
GONNA SUPPORT APPRENTICESHIP
READINESS PROGRAM LET SUPPORT
THE ONE THAT'S LOOKED AT BY THE
CONTRACTORS AND APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT EMPLOY THE
APPRENTICES IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND IN OUR CASE YOU KNOW WE
WILL REPRESENT OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND APPRENTICES IN
CALIFORNIA AND OVER 90% OF ALL
APPRENTICESHIP IN CONSTRUCTION
ONE WE SUPPORT OF A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT
THAT INDUSTRIES LOOK FOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY DONE
A GOOD JOB AT THAT- SOME OF
YOUR NEWER LEGISLATION ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. HAS
WRITTEN IN- STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS WITHIN THE REGION
TO INVOLVE THE WORK FORCE
BOARD- YOUR LOCAL WORKSOURCE
CENTER AND WHERE TO. GET OVER
IT I. RIGHT FUNDING AND SUPPORT
TO GET OVER BARRIERS
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE LOCAL
TRAINING AGENCIES THAT HAVE A
HISTORY OF PARTNERING ON
CURRICULUM AND PARTNERSHIPS
THAT GET INTO THOSE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
THEN- ALSO LOOKING TO LABOR-
YOU KNOW I'M NOT NAIVE TO THINK
THAT EVERY- COUNTY IS LIKE LOS
ANGELES BUT IN IT WEATHERS
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE LET'S COLLABORATE WITH
THE WORK FORCE. YOU KNOW IT
IT'S NO ACCIDENT THAT
CONSTRUCTION OVER THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS HAS TURNED INTO A
GOOD CAREER IT'S HAPPENED BY
HAVING WORKER INVOLVEMENT IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING- BY THE
BY THE MEMBERS AND IT CAN
HAPPEN NOT IN OTHER INDUSTRIES
BUT THE KEY IS TO INVOLVE THE
WORKER AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING BUT I THINK THE
STATE HAS DONE A GOOD JOB ABOUT
CREE THESE PARTNERSHIPS AND THE
NEWER LEGISLATION THAT WE SEE.
IS GETTING BETTER AND BETTER
ALL THE TIME. WHAT WHAT I'VE
SEEN THAT'S BEEN EXTREMELY
HELPFUL IS WHENEVER- MANY OF
THE ORGANIZATION'S PARTICULAR
WHEN CALIFORNIA COMMUTE
COLLEGES ARE WRITTEN INTO THE
BILL TO BE AT THE TABLE TO BE
PART OF THE DISCUSSION THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN VERY HELPFUL- THAT
HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE SO
THAT HAS BEEN. RECENTLY A LOT
OF DIFFERENT BILLS THAT WE'VE
BEEN WRITTEN INTO TO
PARTICIPATE AND IT REALLY HELPS
SORT OF GROW THE ECO SYSTEM
BECAUSE AND BUILD THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS I CAN THINK OF
ONE RECENTLY. THAT HELLO HOW
ARE OVER THAT SHE- CAME CAME
ABOUT BUT AB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
WHERE- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS COMMISSION WORKING
WITH A CALIFORNIA COMMUNE
COLLEGES TO DEVELOP THOSE.
ONLINE TEACHER TRAINING PROGRAM
AND IT BROUGHT US TO THE TABLE
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD A LONG
TRADITION OF PARTNERING
TOGETHER SO THAT WAS VERY. IT
IN AS A PERFORMER CAN CAUSE
STUDENT IS GREAT TO SEE THE
INVOLVEMENT COLLEGES AND
WORKING. AS WE SEE THAT THE
WORK WAS DOUBLE MORE WORKING
WITH S. I. YOU FOR EXAMPLE THE
ON THE HOME CARE WORKERS I
THINK. HAS A SPREAD AROUND THE
STATE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COMPLETE KEY ROLE. IN TRAINING
A LOT OF THESE THESE WORKERS
AND PARENTS AS WELL AND- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT CAME UP IN THE
COMMISSION HEARING YESTERDAY
BECAUSE- HOME CARE WORK KEEPS
COMING UP BECAUSE IT'S ONE OF
THE UNICORN FIELD AND IT'S A
TOTALLY UNDERPAID AND- THERE'S
SO MUCH WICKS THAT. OTHER
ISSUES THAT GO ALONG WITH IT
AND- ONE OF THE FROM THE
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE YESTERDAY
THERE WAS A COMMENT THAT WHILE
WE NEED TO HAVE HIGHER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. UP FOR
THOSE THAT ARE DOING THE WORK-
AND BY SUGGEST THAT MY LOOK THE
MONEY. OVER MANY DECADES AS
PRIVATE SECTOR'S GOT RID OF
PENSIONS THERE'S A REASON WHY
THERE'S SO MANY SENIORS AND
POVERTY. SO I THINK THAT THERE
IS AN APP THERE'S AN ASPECT OF.
OF THESE CORPORATIONS STEPPING
UP THAT HAVE REALLY. PUT BURDEN
ON TO THE PUBLIC OF TAKING CARE
OF OUR SENIORS AND I THINK THAT
THAT HOW YOU CAN. HELP TO FIND.
SOME OF THESE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. INCREASED WAGES
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AND SO I THINK. THAT IF THERE
IS AN ECOSYSTEM. FUNDING PIECE
IS BROKEN. HAS BEEN
INTENTIONALLY KIND OF BROKEN
OVER THE DECADES BUT- I THINK
THAT THE COLLABORATION AND
SHOWING THAT THE MODEL WORKS.
WILL HELP US. BETTER GO AFTER
THE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. AND THEN ON THE
LAST COMMENT I HAVE IS ON THE
PROCUREMENT. I THINK ANY
PROCUREMENT. OR SUBSIDY
SOMETIMES CALLED INCENTIVES BUT
THEIR SUBSIDIES. OF SHOULD COME
WITH GOOD JOBS AND THERE SHOULD
BE A THERE SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND I HAVE HAD
A BILL WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
AT THE WITH THE- PUBLIC THAT.
THAT PULL BRING BACK AGAIN. BUT
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL. THAT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT USING PUBLIC
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THAT THEY'RE
CREATING QUALITY JOBS. AND SO
I'M GLAD TO HEAR. FROM A NUMBER
OF YOU AS WELL AS WAS BROUGHT
UP YESTERDAY IN THE HEARING
THAT. IT'S A THAT'S IMPORTANT
PRIORITY BECAUSE I KNOW FOR
EVERYBODY UP HERE- WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT. SO THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH ANY OF THE LAST CONTRA
QUESTION. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR YOUR INSIGHT-
AND FOR SOME OF THOSE
SUGGESTIONS. AS WELL AS WHAT WE
CAN DO. TO HELP YOU. AND SO AS
THE PANELS SWITCH OUT IN THIS
NEXT PANEL AS A MOVE LOOKING
FORWARD TO BECAUSE WE DO A
DEEPER DIVE INTO THE ACTUAL
PROGRAMS- THAT ARE LIFTING UP
OF. THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY-
THAT- THAT HAVE SO MUCH TO
CONTRIBUTE IN OF OFTENTIMES
BEEN WRITTEN OFF. AND I'M GLAD
TO SEE THAT WERE IN THIS THIS
MOMENT- AWARE. OF LEVY CAN
REALLY SUPPORT- SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS I KNOW A LOT OF THEM
TO WORK WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES- WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
CENTER COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHAT
HAVE YOU BUT THE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HEAR.
SOME OF THE STORIES OF THESE AT
THE ACTUAL PROGRAMS ARE ON THE
GROUND. AND SO- BUT A VERY
HAPPY TO HAVE WITH US. TODAY.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT. I DOCTOR
DOCTOR ON A LOOSE GONZALEZ OF
THE UCLA LABOR CENTER. ESTERS
OF THE MIGUEL CONTRAST
FOUNDATION. DANIEL TOYS FROM
THE FRONT RANGE CENTER AND SKIP
TOWNSEND REPRESENTING SECOND
CALL- EACH PANELIST WILL HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT MINUTES TO SPEAK
AND AGAIN WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AFTER THAT AS WELL.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY OF BEING HERE
I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT AN IMPORTANT INITIATIVE
THE HIGHER TWENTY PARTNERSHIPS
THAT ADVANCED EQUITY AND- JOB
QUALITY FOR MY DRIVES
COMMUNITIES. ASKED HIM SAID
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO THE STATE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS OF ON THE
BOARD FUNDED EIGHT SKILL FOCUS
INDUSTRY BASED PARTNERSHIPS TO
CONNECT LOW WAGE AND MOST CO
WORKERS TO QUALITY CAREER
LADDERS. THAT INCLUDE A CHANGE
CLIMATE CHANGE APPROACH AND A
VISION FOR EQUITY. THE
PARTNERSHIPS. THIS PARTNERSHIP
SPAN SECTORS VITAL TO THE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY HEALTHCARE
HOSPITALITY TRANSIT WATER AND
WASTEWATER BUILDING OPERATIONS
AND TRANSPORTATION LOGISTICS
AND THE PUBLIC SECTOR. HIGHER
TWENTY PARTNERSHIPS INCLUDE
THREE IMPORTANT ACTORS WORK
REPRESENTATIVES EMPLOYER
REPRESENTATIVES AND EIGHTEEN
YEAR. ON THE DEMAND SIDE OF THE
LABOR MARKET ARE EMPLOYERS AND
ON THE SUPPLY SIDE OF THE LABOR
MARKET OUR WORKERS
INTERMEDIARIES RECEIVE SINGLES
FROM BOTH THE EMPLOYER AND THE
WORKER REPRESENTATIVES TO WORK
WITH. WORKERS WORK FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL ADDRESS
BOTH THE DEMAND SIDE AND THE
SUPPLY SIDE OF THE LABOR MARKET.
WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT HIGHER
TWENTY PARTNERSHIPS IS THAT
THEIR INDUSTRY DRIVEN AND
WORKER CENTERED. WORKER AND
EMPLOYER REPRESENTATIVES ARE
THE INDUSTRY EXPERTS AND WORK
TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY SKILL
SOLUTIONS TO INDUSTRY WORKFORCE
NEEDS. IN OTHER WORDS YOU NEED
A WORKER EXPERTISE ON THE WORK
IS VALUED JUST AS HIGHLY AS
EMPLOYER WORK THE PLAYER
KNOWLEDGE AND HOW TO OPERATE IN
THE INDUSTRY. WORKERS ARE
INVALUABLE MEMBERS OF THE
PARTNERSHIP THEY HELPED SHAPE
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND CURRICULA
THE TRAIN OTHER WORKERS AND
THEY ARE AT THE CENTER OF
DEVELOPING INDUSTRY SOLUTIONS.
AS THE EVALUATOR VÀ HIGHER
TWENTY PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE
FOUND THAT HIGHER THE HIGHER
TWENTY PARTNERSHIP APPROACH
CREATE IT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ECOSYSTEM OF ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY. NEW AN INCUMBENT
WORKERS GAIN ACCESS TO TRAINING
PROGRAMS ON THE JOB MENTORING.
AND CAREER PATHWAYS THAT HELP
THEM BE SUCCESSFUL ON THE JOB
IN A CHIEF ECONOMIC SECURITY.
EMPLOYERS GAIN A SKILLED AND
RELIABLE WORKFORCE. SECOND TRIP
THAT IMPROVE THEIR PRODUCTIVITY
AND SELF IS QUALITY OF SERVICE
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
CONTRIBUTING TO INDUSTRY
SOLUTIONS. THAT SECURE
EMPLOYERS COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE. AND ALTHOUGH
PARTNERSHIPS VERY UNSTRUCTURED
USE DIFFERENT STRATEGIES AND
HAVE DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES
THEY SHARE A COMMON BROAD GOAL.
TO BUILD AN ECONOMY BASED ON
SKILLS INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY
SUSTAINABILITY ENSURE
PROSPERITY. NOW I'M GOING TO
PROVIDE SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW
THESE PARTNERSHIPS LOOK LIKE ON
THE GROUND. THE FIRST TWO OR
HIGHER TWENTY PARTNERSHIPS
FUNDED BY THE HARBOR. RAINY
PARTNERSHIP INITIATIVE THANK.
AND THE LAST EXAMPLE IS OF IN A
HIGHER TWENTY PARTNERSHIP BY A
WORKER CENTER. EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCE THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. EMPLOYERS
INTERNATIONAL UNION LOCAL
MENTAL. WITH SUPPORT FROM THE
HIGHER TWENTY PARTNERSHIP
INITIATIVE THE WORKER EDUCATION
RESOURCE CENTER IS DEVELOPING
LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S FIRST HI
ROAD PARTNERSHIP MODEL. WORK IS.
WE PROGRAM CALLED PREPARE FOR
COUNTY. REPRESENT A COMMUNITY.
COUNTY APPOINT QUALIFICATION
YOUR JOBS. THE PRINCE INCLUDE
PEOPLE WHO WAS. WHO LIVE IN
ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED AREAS
WERE INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM HOMELESSNESS OR
HOUSING AND SECURE OR OTHERWISE
UNDER REPRESENTED. IT'S SOUTH
LOS ANGELES THE WORKERS. YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR TO
BECOME EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS AND CREATIVE WAYS
THAT LEAD TO. COMMENT IN
ADDITION. FOR MTV'S THE WORKER
AND EDUCATE RESOURCE CENTER IS
HELPING DIVERSE OF BY THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE WITH
MEDICAL EMERGENCY TECHNICIANS
FROM THE COMMUNITY AND. ANOTHER
HI WE'RE TWENTY IS THE BUILDING
SKILLS PARTNERSHIP OR PSP WE
THANKS RESPONSIBLE BILL THE-
LAWYERS JENNIFER. AND THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION UNITED SERVICE WORKERS
LAST TO CREATE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
HEALTHIER WORK WERE.
MARGINALIZED STORY A WORKER
WALKS STRAIGHT. TO COMPLY GREEN.
IS A LOT. AND WORK WITH LOW
LEVELS OF IT. PSP IS
PROFESSIONALLY PROPERTY SERVICE.
OFFERING A GREEN SKILLS
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT SURPRISE
WORKERS IS THE INABILITY PROPER
PRACTICES PROMOTING. BRIDGE
PROGRAMS TO SPECIALIZE
JANITORIAL APPRENTICESHIPS VSP
OFFERS WORKS A TREAT IN THE
CORPORATE'S WORST WORKER WISDOM
IN CURRICULA DEVELOPMENT. EVERY
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF PROGRAM
MEET STREET TEN STAFF. MY FINAL
PARTNERSHIP EXAMPLE IS A WORKER
CENTER THAT IS ADOPTING THE
HYBRID APPROACH THE DRESS. I
MEANT IN THE LOS ANGELES WORK
BETTER. COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR AND MAYOR CARCETTI TO
IMPROVE TO IMPLEMENT A CAMPAIGN
TO PLACE OF RESIDENCE IN HIGH.
INCLUDING A HISTORY OF RACIAL
AND HOMELESSNESS THE JOBS. THE
BLACK WORKERS CENTERS GOAL IS
TO DEVELOP A PROCESS TO
ACCELERATE TARGET. GOALS
THROUGH ACTIVE COLLABORATION
WITH. AND UNIONS. PLANS TO.
ELIGIBLE FOR. IMPLEMENT WORKER
WORKPLACE MENTORSHIP. PROGRAMS
INCREASE THE IMPLEMENTATION.
RIGHT. USING. AS WE LOOK AT HOW
ON A MISSION. EN MASSE
RETIREMENT ARE CHANGING THE
FUNDAMENTAL NATURE OF WORK YOU
MUST PAY ATTENTION TO
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ADDRESS THE
SHIPS WHILE ENSURING. WE ARE AT
THE CENTER OF NEW DEVELOPMENT.
WOMEN AND INVESTOR PAUL. A
LABOR COMMAND POLICYMAKERS
BUSINESS YOU. WORKERS CENTERS
AND THE WORKFORCE SYSTEM.
FRAMEWORK. RIGHT HI WILL TWENTY
PARTNERSHIP THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
THAT INCLUDES WORK AND OTHERS
WHO ARE NOT IN THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM. SEC EQUITY.
FOR JOHN WE CAN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. IN OUR PLEASE.
CITIES COUNTY. EIGHT FOR.
RECEIVE PUBLIC THAT'S MEANT
PUBLIC. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SHOULD I LOST HIS AND THANK YOU
THE LABOR CENTER HOWEVER THE
LITTLE IF YOU AND HELPING YOU
IN FOR. WHAT WE DOING. THERE'S
EXCEPT IN ASTROS WITH THE
MIGUEL CONTROLLERS FOUNDATION.
RUNNING EVERYONE THEN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
THINK ABOUT I AM. FOR THE.
FIRST FOUNDATION AND THE
FOUNDATION I ONE SEE THREE PART
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY FEDERAL
LABOR. THE WORST FORM THE
FOUNDATION IS. ONE THOUSAND
NINE TWO. COLOR WOMEN. NOT A.
WE ARE. WITH HE- LÀ TITLES
ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL COURSE THE FEDERATION
OF LABOR. ON ANTAR DIVISION
COLETTE IN SOUTHWEST. THE SHIP
READING THIS PROGRAM THAT WAS
DESIGNED AND CREATED- FOR
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL. BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION. BUT YOU KNOW
CONSTRUCTION IS ONE OF THE MORE
FORGIVING INDUSTRIES FOR
INDIVIDUAL WHAT I LIKE TO SAY
WITH COLORFUL SO THIS. IS IT IS.
REALLY WHERE WE YOU KNOW WHERE.
CONSTRUCTION AND. THERE'S A BIG
SCHOOL FITNESS COME. WELL YOU
WILL SEE IN SOME OF THE I YOU
KNOW HE THERE'S THERE ARE.
THERE'S TRAUMA INFORMED CARE WE
TO OPEN A. AS THEIR AS WE CAN
SO ONCE. GET THESE UPPER. YOU
KNOW THIS BROWN WE DO DRUG
TESTING ON THE OTHER DRUG TEST
THE PROGRAM. DURING THE COURSE
OF THE THREE MONTHS THE
PARTICIPANTS AND SEVEN. OKAY
OUR- NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED YOU
KNOW- OSHA TEN OF COURSE WAS
THE MENTION OF SAFETY SAFETY OF
THE MOST IMPORTANCE YOU KNOW
FIRST AID CPR LAW ON TO A
CONFINED SPACE CERTIFICATION
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL SAFETY
AWARENESS SERVICE. THIS
UPCOMING. TWO HOUSES FORTY OUR
SORT OF- WHAT- SO IN A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT IN. SO IT'S A IT'S A
REAL GREAT PROPERTY FOR D.
CLOSE TO NOT ONLY CHANGED
THERE. BUT THE ONES NO TO THEM
AS. YOU KNOW MISTER RANEY HAD
MADE AND- ONE OF THE DRIVE WITH
STEVE. YOU KNOW. SITUATIONS
WHERE THERE WERE WERE CHANGE IN
WHAT IS NOW WE'RE WE'RE
BREAKING THE CYCLE ARE PART OF
THE PROBLEM IS TO BREAK THE
CYCLE OF IN CARS THE GENERAL
THE GENERATIONAL. THE CYCLE OF
INCARCERATION. HAD SEVERAL.
EIGHTY EIGHT THERE AND SISTER
COMPLETAR COHORT AND GOING TO
UNION BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES- WE'VE HAD A FATHER AND
SON YOU KNOW THE FOR- WENT
THROUGH FIRST THE SUN SO HERE.
GOES SOMETHING ONLY THE STRONG.
WITHOUT SISTERS OF THE- POOR I
GRADUATED FROM WHAT IS NOW A
PLUMBER IN A LETTER. ON THIS
THIS. WELL WE HAD A FOCAL
GRADUATED PREVIOUS COHORT HIS
NEPHEW JUST GRADUATED SO. AND
I'M HEARING STORE. OF. YOU KNOW
THE VISUALS KIDS. USED TO
SEEING THEIR PARENTS WALDRON
SOME. A HEALTHY LIFESTYLE YOU
KNOW SOMEONE HELP THE I.
GETTING UP. GOING TO WORK IN A
TRADE PROUD OF WHAT THEY'RE
LEARNING IN THE PAST THAT DOWN
TO THEIR- FAMILY MEMBER SORTS
IT'S. JUST THE INDIVIDUAL YOU
KNOW I'VE HEARD THE TERM.
CHANGE YOUR ALL CHAMPIONS OF
CHANGE UP HERE WOULD BE A- PART
OF THE PROCESS TO CHANGE THAT
DOM CYCLECARS RATIO THE
RECIDIVISM- ANNA IT'S REALLY.
IMPOSSIBLE. UP HERE WITH SOME
INDIVIDUALS THAT I. WHEN THIS.
AND. ENGINE THE LANDSCAPE IN
THE QUEUE. YOU'RE THE DO SOME
SIMILAR WORK YOU KNOW OUR OUR
PROGRAM. YOU KNOW THERE'S
SEVERAL COMPONENTS TO. THEY
RECEIVE THEM. CURRICULUM WHICH
THERE'S A BELIEVE NINETY TO.
I'LL BUT WE DO SOME OTHER WELL
YOU KNOW. GO ON HIKES MONTHLY
THERE HI. JUST A BILL THAT
BONTA COMMUNITY IN OF COURSE
BUILD UP YOU PHYSICAL STAMINA
BUT THEY'RE DOING HIKES MONTHLY
YOU KNOW MOUNT WILSON HOLLYWOOD
SIGN. BUT YOU MUST GO AND. YOU
NEED TO BUILD ON THE FIRST ONE
IN THE NUMBER OF THE COMMUNITY-
THEIR THEIR PART OF BEING ON IN
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW COMING EVERY. FOR MY
CAR. HELLO BUT REQUIRE TO GET
IN THE PROGRAM SO YOU KNOW ON
TRAUMA THAT COMES ALONG WITH
THAT. RECENTLY PARTNER CAN CALL
WHO'S BEEN DOING SOME GREAT.
YEARS OF. THAT. SO YOU KNOW HE
I THANK YOU LA BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL NO OF OUR CORE PARTNER.
YOU KNOW WE. WELL WHICH IS
IMPORTANT. RITUALS MATTER
STANDING HE GOT BILLS YOU GOTTA
PAY. TO PROVIDE THAT INCOME YOU
KNOW IT IS A IT IS YOU KNOW
ALLOWS PEOPLE THAT OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T. PROGRAM PLEASE LISTEN
NOW THAT JOB WHICH YOU KNOW ARE
WE ALL KNOW WHAT THE ACRONYM
FOR JOBS JUST AN ACRONYM FOR
JUST OVER BROKE THEY CAN MOVE
AWAY FROM THAT JOB INTO A
CAREER YOU KNOW AND FORCE THEM
OPPORTUNITY WITH THAT STYLE.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT INCOME- YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD. WE STARTED WE
HAD OUR FIRST CALL WORK JUST
GRATITUDE GRADUATED. ON MARCH
EIGHTH COHORT ON NOVEMBER
FIRST- WE'VE WE'VE- GRADUATED.
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR INDIVIDUALS
PLACED AUBURN FORTY. IN UNION
BUILDING A JUNCTION TRADE
CAREER SO YOU KNOW WE BROUGHT
US. BUT THAT'S BECAUSE WE JUST
GRABBED LAST NOVEMBER FIRST WE
USUALLY WE AROUND 80% 83% THE
LAST GRADUATION. YOU KNOW WE
THE RETENTION RATE IS HOT I
KNOW WE. FOLLOW UP WITH THE-
RULES BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST THE-
M. WE PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT. SO
FAR THANK YOU. MAYBE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE WITH A- THE
PROGRAM IN THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING SOMETHING. CAN
CONNECTING. TO WIN A COUPON
CAN. WELL BECAUSE IT IS A
CLASS. SO THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR
THAT. POOREST OF THE BRIDGE
CENTER. A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM MY NAME IS DANIEL AND
FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU I SAY THAT BECAUSE MY
PERSONAL LIFE HAS BEEN. ONLY
IMPACTED BY THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS. BUT I'M FORMALLY
INCARCERATED FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH BETWEEN THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY THREE IN NOT A CAR
SERRATION AND AT TWENTY THREE I
GOT NOW AND I REALIZE THAT A
FORK IN THE ROAD. AND I TWO
CHILDREN AT THE TIME AND I. I
WAS AT A FORK IN TO ME WAS VERY
THIS DATA I EITHER DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. I'M GOOD. READY FOR
TWENTY YEARS. I'M SORRY. SOME
PROGRAM TWO DAYS AFTER
GRADUATING. I BECAME LAW FOR
STONE MADE. AND IT WAS A FOR
SOME OF A LIFE I HAVE SEEN.
ROLE MODEL AND I WAS. ENTIRE
FAMILY OF MY FATHER'S A
IMMIGRANT FROM NOW ON A BOTTLE
AND IS JUST TO KIND OF SEE SOME
OF THE STRUGGLE LITTLE DID I
KNOW AT THAT TIME THAT I PLAYED
A ROLE IN KIND OF. EXPAND THESE
OPPORTUNITIES A STATE IT IS
THAT I ENVISIONED MYSELF BUT
IT'S REALLY AMAZING. THAT I'M
AT I'M ACTUALLY ABLE TO BE A-
WORK. THERE'S SO MANY PARTNERS
IN THIS WORK AND- JUST GIVE A
LITTLE. TENER NUMBER CENTER WAS
A GRANT GIVING FOUNDATION FOR
THE BETTER THIRTY YEARS- THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AS DECIDING
TO SUNSET THE LAST BIT OF OUR
FOUNDATION DOCTORS. WE WANT
SAYS. THE GAPS IN SERVICES WERE.
US SEVENTY. HERE KEPT COMING UP
IS THAT PEOPLE COME FROM
GRAYSON HAD LITTLE TO NO OUT TO.
OF SERVICES FOR WOMEN
OPPORTUNITIES. WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO THIS OKAY.
SO THIS AND WE COULDN'T FIND
ANY OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
OUR AREA WHERE FROM PASADENA.
YOU KNOW A PRETTY. A FLUENT
COMMUNITY WHERE A LOT. OF
PEOPLE KIND A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE SO WITH RE ENTRY
ALREADY AND ALL DIFFERENT IS
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING HERE
TODAY ARE KIND OF- BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE HAVE. WE HAVE ALL THESE
WONDERFUL THINGS. MONEY WELL IN
THIS IN A. ONE ONE OF MY
COWORKERS ALWAYS THIS IS. THE
DEAN IS THE CITY OF ROSES AND
ROSES ARE BEAUTIFUL. POINTS TO
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE DO WORK
WITH. AND. WE STARTED OFF
DOING. IT WAS VERY. A WELL
INTENTIONED HEARTED. GOOD FOR
EFFORT TO WORK WITH PEOPLE.
MANY CARS RATED. DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT
AND. THESE ARE MY THESE ARE
PHARMACIES ANSWERS OUR UNCLE.
ONE OKAY WELL WAY I LIKE TO
ILLUSTRATE THAT IS YOU KNOW IF
MY IF MY DAUGHTER TOOK A DOLLAR
OUT OF MY WALLET WITHOUT ASKING
AND I FOUND OUT I WOULD TALK TO
UNTIL IT WOULD AGAIN AND THAT'S
THE END OF IT BUT WHAT WE DO AS
A SOCIETY IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS WE CAN'T
PUNISH. STEP IN EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AFTER THE. THE TIME FOR
WHATEVER. CRIME WHAT IS IT THAT
THEY CAN. I DON'T USE THAT
PERSON INCARCERATE BUT THERE WE
NOW HAVE ACCESS LEAST LESS
OPPORTUNITY. WROTE UPWARD
MOBILITY ALL DIFFERENT THINGS I
AM KIND OF CYCLE OF VIOLENCE
FROM. THIS HAD NOTHING TO.
NUMBER WORKFORCE US.
CONSTRUCTION FROM. SOMEBODY'S
BACKGROUND- QUICKLY WE FOUND
OUT THAT CONSTRUCTION THE SAME.
WE WERE SEVEN PEOPLE OFF TO GO
NONUNION COP IS IN. BE
EXPLOITED AND TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF SO FOR US OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
FOCUS ON WHAT IS THE BEST
INTEREST FOR THE PEOPLE WERE
WORKING WITH. CONTINUE TO GUIDE
AND- MOVE. IT WOULD IN KEEPING
THAT IN MIND. WE'RE WE'RE ON
THE RIGHT TRACK. NOT TO BE IS
THAT. ABOUT MEANING AGES UPPER
MOBILITY- PENSION RETIREMENT OF
FULL HEALTH BENEFITS ALL THINGS
I GOT TO EXPERIENCE ON THE
FIRST HAND YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW
GOOD IT FELT TO- I HAVE TO CALL
MY LANDLORD AND TELLER THAT THE.
YOU KNOW MY KIDS UP AND SHOW UP
AT OUR HOUSE AND BACK. TO YOU
MAKE THIS. THAT POINT AND. ZERO
INVESTMENT THE I DIDN'T HAVE TO
COME OUT OF MY POCKET AT ALL
DOES IT AND BIGGER THAN THAT I
CIRCLE EVERYBODY THAT WAS
ATTACHED TO ME MY BROTHER.
FRIENDS THAT WERE ALSO INVOLVED.
NOT THE MOST PRODUCTIVE. THINGS
IN THE COMMUNITY STARTED SEEING
THIS CHANGE WANTED TO GET
INVOLVED MOST OF THEM MOST OF
MY VERY CLOSE FRIENDS ARE ALL
TRADESMEN JOURNEYMEN MAKING
GREAT MONEY TAKING CARE OF
THEIR FAMILIES. SO THIS IMPACT.
IT WOULD A CANCER IT IS IT'S
REALLY A HARD THING TO FOLLOW
SO WE SAW. HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH- THE LA IN ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL SUPER
FRUITFUL BUT A COUPLE OF JUST
WHAT WON OUT KIND OF REITERATE
THE FOR. ABOUT IS OUT THEM. BOB
ARE USED TO THESE UNION. IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO PREPARE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY AND GET
ON INTO THESE OPPORTUNITIES SO
THAT'S THAT'S A HUGE SUPER
IMPORTANT ARM. AND IT TAKES A
VILLAGE. IT IS NOT THIS WERE
NOT THE SPECIALIST IN AND BEING
VOTE WHAT I LIKE TO THINK.
LISTEN AGAIN TO FIND THIS LIST
THAT ARE SPECIALIZING IN WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL OR SAY WE DO IT ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND THE PEOPLE THAT
DO IT AND DO IT REALLY WELL AND
HAVE THEM. OF PART OF THE TEAM
THAT'S WHAT WE WANNA DO AND
IT'S BEEN REALLY IMPACT ONE
REALLY WELL- WE'VE TRAVELED
DATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH A
CALIFORNIA WORK FORCE TO. BOARD
IT WAS FUNNY BECAUSE I USE THAT
LENDERS WERE THIS ANNA WE GOT
THIS WE DO. BUT WHAT I LEARNED
VERY QUICKLY. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THERE'S NO
ORGANIZATION. THAT TO.
FRIENDSHIP IS PROGRAMS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS WORK. LOCATE AND
POOR- WHATEVER OVER THERE
CERTAIN STANCES ARE AND I AM SO
MUCH. I FELT THAT I GAVE.
TRAINING GROUPS AND BROUGHT
PEOPLE TO BRING STUFF BACK DOWN
THE PASADENA INTO A LAKE THAT
REALLY IS CHANGE THE WAY THAT
WE DO THIS PRE APPRENTICESHIP
QUIRK. X. UPGRADE I MEAN IT IS
A MODEL SHIP I WANT TO SHARE
STUFF BECAUSE WE'RE DATA DATA
PEOPLE. WE UNDERSTAND HOW IS
IMPORTANT- SO WE HAVE THIS-
SYSTEM WHERE WE'RE TRACKING
EVERYBODY AND- SO THAT THE
OWNER. OF THE AIRPORT OUR. ON
THE INVESTED IN IN. TRAINING.
WORK ON THE PROJECT. GOING ON
AT LOS ANGELES WORLD AIRPORTS
AND SO THE- PROGRAMS ABOUT TWO
YEARS OLD MAYBE A LITTLE LESS
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. DUMB OUT OF
THE HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT PLACE
AND GOOD PAYING CAREERS WERE
ABLE THE SEVEN OF THEM LOOK AT
HOW MUCH THEY'VE EARNED FOR
THEIR FAMILIES- OUT OF THE
EIGHTY SEVEN PEOPLE. THEY
WORKED A TOTAL OF EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND HOURS ON LOS ANGELES
WORLD AIRPORTS THEY'VE EARNED
TWO POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
ON SO THINK ABOUT IF WE'RE ABLE
TO SET THE SYSTEM UP. THE MODEL
IS THERE ACROSS DIFFERENT
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SAY THE CAPITOL
BUILDINGS THAT SAM WAS TALKING
ABOUT OR WHATEVER IS GOING ON
THE SACRAMENTO. THE SYSTEMS
EXIST AND EVEN FURTHER MORE
WERE ABLE TO TRACK HOW MANY
WOMEN ARE WORKING WHICH FOR
THIS PROJECT IT'S 13% WHICH IS
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE STANDARD
CONSTRUCTION- INDUSTRY WHICH IS
LIKE 223% AFRICAN AMERICANS- IS
55% WHICH IS MUCH HIGHER THAN
THE STANDARD BUILDING TRADES-
LATINOS IS ABOUT 35% FIVE OR 6%
CAUCASIAN- BUT WERE ABLE TO SEE
EVEN. EVEN BASED BY RACE AND
GENDER WHAT HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY'RE BRINGING BACK TO THE-
TO THEIR COMMUNITY NOW ALL
THESE PEOPLE LIVE WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY THEY'RE PAYING TAXES
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY THEY'RE
BUYING GAS. SB ONE SHADOW THANK
YOU FOR SB ONE YEAH THIS I MEAN
THIS GOOD STUFF GOOD STUFF
GOING ON THERE BUT THEY BY GAS
THERE SO I MEAN IF WE START
LOOKING AT THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR WHAT WE'RE-
INVESTING AT THE STATE LEVEL
INTO THESE HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREER
PARTNERSHIPS. WE COULD REALLY
SEE THAT IT'S A GOOD THING FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU
WELL FIRST OFF THANKS FOR
SAYING SOMETHING NICE FOR THE
GAS TAX. REFRESHING. AND YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOBODY MINIMAL
DORIAN WAS TALKING ABOUT DANIEL
ABOUT BREAKING THAT CYCLE AND
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE INVEST IN
PEOPLE WITHOUT JUDGEMENT. AND
KNOW THAT UP AND HELP YOU REACH
YOUR POTENTIAL MEANS BEAUTIFUL
TO HEAR YOUR STORY YOU'RE A
WONDERFUL SPOKESPERSON FOR WHY
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THESE
PROGRAMS- AND THEN FINALLY SKIP
TOWNSEND. YES INDEED THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. MY STORY IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT- I ACTUALLY HAD A
CAREER I WAS DOING GREAT AND I
WANTED TO STOP THE VIOLENCE IN
MY COMMUNITY. SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IDEA IT IS- SAID
WELL I BECAME A COMMERCE OF
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS BECAUSE I
DISCOVERED SOMETHING A FATHER
GREG BOYLE WAS ALREADY DOING.
WHICH IS GETTING PEOPLE JOBS-
BUT AS DORIAN SAID IT IS NOT
JUST OVER BROKE IT WAS A
JOURNEY OF THE BROKE SO I WAS
HELPING PEOPLE GET IN THE JOBS
BUT WHAT THEY WERE DOING IS
THEY WERE SHOWING UP LATE. THEY
WERE SHOWN UP HIGH THEY WERE
SHOWING UP DRUNK THEY WORK ONE
WE CAN QUIT AND I WAS FINE IN
THAT- A LOT OF EMPLOYERS WILL
CALL ME BACK SAYING HEY WE
DON'T WANT ANYMORE YOUR PEOPLE
SO. DON'T BRING THEM- THAT WAS
UNTIL I DISCOVERED THAT I
NEEDED TO USE WORKSOURCE
CENTERS I NEEDED TO USE. SOME
OF THE PARTNERS IN THE
COMMUNITY TO HELP THEM-
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
A JOB AND HOW TO KEEP IT. SO
WHAT I WOULD DO IS USE MY OWN
VAN- AND FIRST OF ALL THIS IS
NO FIND IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
DARTED SECOND CALL I WOULD TAKE
MY OWN VAN AND GATHER ALL THE
DRIVE BY SHOOTERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND THE NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITY AND TAKEN TO THE
WORKSOURCE CENTERS AND- TEACH
THEM HOW TO GET A JOB AND WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IS THEY WOULD COME
BACK ON THE BLOCK IN A- TIE ON.
AND HAVE A RESUME ROLLED UP IN
THEIR BACK POCKET BUT THEY WERE
STILL SMOKIN AND DRINKIN AND
DOING THE SAME THINGS THAT THEY
WERE DOING THEY JUST KNOW HOW
TO RESUME IN A TIME ON. I'M
SORRY I REALIZE THAT THIS WAS
A- BAD INFLUENCE AS MUCH AS I
WANTED THEM DATING ONE FOR
THEMSELVES. I MET A GUY NAMED
JOHN AREA- WHO IS THAT TIME
THIRTEEN YEARS IN THE-
POLITICAL UNIONS- THIRTY IT
JUST BECAME A FULL TIME AND- HE
WAS EXPRESSING THE ME THEY DO
HAVE A GREAT COMPONENT. WITH
THE CURRICULUM WITH YES I
RECOMMEND HE HAD. TO SAY AND
STOP DO THE WORK. SO I COULD
NOT IDENTIFY. NOT WHAT THE
INDIVIDUALS A RUN INTO BUT HELP
THEM IDENTIFY WHAT THEY WERE
RUNNING FROM. AND THAT'S WHEN
WE GOT THE UNRESOLVED IN
VICARIOUS TRAUMA. SO FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE AND- LET ME GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO AND- A PRAYER FOR
EVERYONE IN SAUGUS FROM
YESTERDAY- IN SANTA CLARITA.
BUT WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO IS THE
NEXT PERSON TO WANT TO HURT
SOMEONE. SO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
IS GIVE THEM AN EMOTIONALLY
SAFE PLACE. TO TALK ABOUT HOW
DO YOU DEAL WITH ANGER HOW DO
YOU DEAL WITH EMOTIONS ON THE
DEAL WITH LOW SELF ESTEEM. HOW
DO YOU DEAL WITH TRAUMA. AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THAT- THE
TRAUMA- THERE'S PTSD IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND LET ME JUST SAY
AS A LIFETIME RESIDENT OF SOUTH
CENTRAL. THERE IS NO PTSD AND
THAT COMMUNITY- BECAUSE IT'S
NOT POLLS IS CONSTANTLY
REOCCURRING. THAT MAKES IT
PRESENT. STRESS PRESENT TRAUMA
THAT STILL IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND A LOT OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE LEARNED HOW TO- WANNA SAY
SELF MEDICATE WHETHER IT'S BY
USE OF DRUGS WHETHER IT'S BY-
ALCOHOL OR WHATEVER FORM- THEY
CHOOSE TO RUN TO. BUT WHAT'S
MOST IMPORTANT FOR ME. IS HOW
DO I HELP THEM. WITH THE
HEALING PROCESS. SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE AND SECOND CALL IS YEAH
WE'RE CONNECTED TO- AND AT THIS
TIME- JOHN IS. A WHAT IS HE'S A
SUPERINTENDENT A REGIONAL
SUPERINTENDENT FOR MORE MEDALS
AND- BUT IN CHARGE OF DIVERSION
AN INCLUSION FOR HIS COMPANY.
SO AS A SUPERINTENDENT BUT WE
HAVE OF THOSE WHO HAVE COME TO
OUR PROGRAM NOW WHICH STARTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. CORE IN A
POSITION OF POWER. WE FOR OPENS
GENERAL. FOREMAN'S AND
SUPERINTENDENT WHO ARE ARE.
ACTIVISTS ILLUSTRATORS WHO COME
FROM THE COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE
NOT I HAVE NOTHING AGAINST AN
APPRENTICE BUT THEY'RE NOT A
FRIEND IS. THERE NOT JUST
JOURNEYMEN THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
CAN SAY LOOK I CAN HELP YOU GET
INTO THE CAREER I CAN ACTUALLY
HELP YOU GET ON MY JOB. IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO GO THROUGH
THE TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
CLASSES THAT WE FACILITATE I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT IS TO
HAVE PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE- AND YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH I'M I'M INSIDE THE
PRISONS AND WORK IN THE
PRISONS. WHERE INDIVIDUAL SAYS
I NEED TO LEARN A TRADE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I DO WANT
TO HELP THEM LEARN A TRADE BUT
FIRST ONE ON ONE HELP THEM DO
IS BECOME A BETTER PERSON.
BECAUSE AYE AYE HER CHRIS
SAYING THAT- CHRISTIAN
CHRISTIAN AND SAYING THAT WE
WERE INTRODUCED THEM TO THE MC
THREE CURRICULUM. SO ALL THE
TRADES RIGHT SO THAT THEY CAN
CHOOSE BECAUSE BECOME A SECOND
CALLING ON TRY TO MAKE YOU A
ELECTRICITY NOT JUST A- THAT
NOW BUT- YOU KNOW WE DO. DEAL
WITH THE CARPENTERS AND SHEET
METAL AND WE HAVE OTHERS
PARTNERS AS WELL. BUT WHAT I
WANT TO DO IS. I DON'T CARE
WHAT. PATHWAY THEY CHOOSE AS
FAR AS CONSTRUCTION AND I HEARD
SOMETHING ABOUT- CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT AND THINGS OF THIS
NATURE. BUT HOW CAN WE MAKE
THEM A BETTER PERSON NOT JUST
SO THEY WHEN THEY GO OUT ON THE
WORK SITE. BUT ALSO WHEN I GO
HOME AT NIGHT AS DANIEL SAID
WITH THEIR FAMILIES. HOW CAN WE
HELP THEM- CHANGE THE DIRECTION
THAT THE FAMILY IS GOING IN.
AND I THINK THAT WAS A GREAT
EXAMPLE TO TIM SAID. EARLIER
ABOUT THE- GUY SAID HIS SON IS
NOW PUT ON HIS HARD HAT AND
BOOTS. BECAUSE OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS PICKING UP A GUN.
THAT HIS SON EVENTUALLY WILL BE
PICKING UP A GUN AS WELL. SO
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS JUST HELP
THE FAMILY BECOME WHOLE AGAIN.
AND HELP THEM WITH THE PROCESS
OF HEALING SO THAT THEY CAN GO
TO WORK AT LA ACTS- SO THEY CAN
GO TO WORK IT AROUND STADIUM OR
ANYONE THESE PROJECTS. SO I
THINK PARTNERSHIP IS GREAT AND
I'M TRULY GRATEFUL TO BE ONE OF
THE PARTNERS WITH THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SKIP FOR A-
TWO YEAR COMMITMENT FOR GIVING
EVERYTHING UP TO LIFT UP YOUR
COMMUNITY- IT'S A QUITE
INSPIRING AND- BEFORE I BRING
IT BACK I WAS WANT TO GIVE ALL
OF UKIAH THIRTY SECOND
LIGHTNING ROUND. OF WHAT YOU
WOULD WANT US TO COULD BE
BUDGET MAYBE THERE'S SOME
REGULATION THAT'S- KEEPING YOU
FROM HELPING SOME YOUR CLIENTS
WHAT HAVE YOU- WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS THERE IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT IS CONSTANTLY.
IF NOT THAT'S FINE OR IF IT
COULD REPEAT SOMETHING THAT YOU
HEARD EARLIER. THAT'S FINE TOO.
MANY THINGS ANYTHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING. COULD DO
BUDGET. MY TO HELP. FEEL FREE.
OF OUR ORDER ANYWAY I'LL START
THAT YOU KNOW FOR MOST OF THE
PROGRAMS I HEAR ABOUT. THE GRAY
AREA IS THAT AREA THAT I JUST
ADDRESS. THE GRAY AREA IS THE-
GETTING THE HEALTHY PEOPLE WHEN
I AND I LOVE- LOLA AND ALL THE
PEOPLE WITH THE BLACK WORKERS
CENTER. BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY SEE AS WELL IS- WE
DON'T SEE PEOPLE OF OUR COLOR
OUT THERE SO. AS DANIEL SAID LA
X. HAS 55% WHICH IS HIGHER
THAN. MOST ANY OTHER COMPANIES-
BUT THE GRAY AREAS GETTING
HEALTHY BLACK PEOPLE I DON'T
WANT TO GET BLACK PEOPLE ON THE
WORK SITE. JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY'RE FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS AS
WE HAVE TO HIRE FROM THIS. I
WANT TO GET THE HEALTHY ONES
OUT THERE. THE HEALTHY ONES WHO
WON'T AS WE CALL IT
EMBARRASSES. AND THIS IS A GRAY
AREA SO I WOULD SAY WE HAVE TO
INVEST MORE. IN THIS AREA. OKAY
IN ALL OF ITS A SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS THAT HE'LL SOME OF THE
FIRST OF THAT YOU CAN BE
PREPARED TO SUCCEED IN THOSE
PROGRAMS. OKAY ANY OTHER
COMMENT ON YOUTH IN ENGLISH
ALLOWED DURING THOUGHT. PLEASE
SO YOU KNOW WE CAN GET UP HERE
AND TALK ABOUT IT BUT I THINK
IT'S MOST IMPACTFUL TO HEAR
FROM. YOU KNOW SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEEN THROUGH THE PROGRAM. NOT A
GERMAN HERE TODAY MISTER SAM
OKAY AS A GRADUATE OF OUR- OUR-
SEVEN COHORT. AND I YOU KNOW I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO FOR HIM TO
SHARE YOU KNOW HIS EXPERIENCE
WITH. ALL WORK AND NO ALL HIS
YOU KNOW. CAREER AS- LABOR. SO
IN A FEW IN FEEL. WILL GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE UP
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL HAVING HIM
GO FIRST- BUT THAT IT JUST IN A
IN IN A HANDFUL OF MINUTES
WE'LL GET TO THAT- GAS ACTUALLY
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING- BUT
THAT JOURNEY. ANYTHING ELSE- I
FOR ME- I DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM TO PITCH OR- A BUT I
HAVE A VALUE WAITED HIGHER
TWENTY PARTNERSHIPS. AND WHAT'S
BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT LIGHTNING
IS. YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO
FUND. ORGANIZATIONS TO THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CREATE SYSTEM
CHANGE. AND. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO THEN
FUNDING. ORGANIZATIONS. MAYBE
CALL OUTSIDE OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM LIKE WORKER
CENTERS IN DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS. I THINK IT'S
REALLY PART TO HAVE THAT THAT
INTERMEDIARY TO THEN. DEVELOP
PROGRAMS IDENTIFY SPECIAL IF
YOU KNOW SPECIAL- OR
COMPREHENSIVE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SOLUTIONS- AND BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT FUNDING
WILLIAM. I THINK THINGS. AND.
WE DEFINE WHICH IS STRICTLY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT- THAT
COULD I ALSO SUPPORTING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND DANIEL YEAH
FOR ME I GOT TOO MUCH ON.
INDUSTRY EVEN IF WE BRING IT UP
TODAY BUT- YEAH DEFINITELY
FUNDING FOR COMMITTEE BUT
HONEST THIS AND WE'RE EVER
GONNA OF BRING THESE PART HAS
BEEN FROM LIKE A GOOD IN EIGHT
THE END OF COMMUNITIES OR-
SINCE. HIS HONEST. LEVELS OF
TAPE ARE MUCH. SOME OF THE
REGULATIONS AROUND THAT MIGHT
BE. IN PLACE FOR A COURSE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. COOKING FOR
THE COMPANY BASED ORGANIZATION
HAVE BECAUSE IT'S JUST PURE
MUST. AND IT JUST IT THERE'S A
LOT OF ISSUES AROUND THAT- ALSO
I LOVE TO SEE MORE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS- ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT HELP US. THESE
HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION. CAREER
PROGRAMS INCREASE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTION COM. WELL THANK YOU
ALL VERY VERY MUCH AND- I LOVE
THE CONNECTION THAT YOU'RE
MAKING BE. SUPPORTED SERVER IS
AND ALSO CAREERS NOT JUST A JOB
FOR A FEW MONTHS AND THEN. TRY
TO FIND SOMETHING ELSE JUST
LIKE ROLLING AROUND. AND SO THE
CONNECTION TO CAREERS OF THE
CONNECTION TO THE SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED- AND
FRAZIER LEE. OR THE THIRD
COLLECTED. A RELATIONSHIP IS SO
IMPORTANT BACK TOWARD THE UP
CHRIS. THIS IS BEING INVESTED
BY PRIVATE EMPLOYERS INTO
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT'S
A HUGE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S AN ENORMOUS
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT THAT MUCH MONEY IS BEING
NEGOTIATED IF IT WASN'T FOR THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
TWO HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
WILL NOT BE GOING INTO OUR CUT
THESE TO HELP A. AND YOU WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR MAKING
THOSE KIND OF CONNECTIONS AND-
BROTHER WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
CABIN HEALTHY. INDEED GOING
PROGRAM APPRECIATE. OTHER WAYS
WE SORT OF SET UP PEOPLE
FAILURE OF AND THAT NOT RIGHT
EITHER THEY SHOULD. CHANGE.
I'VE SEEN OF I CAME OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL THE INDUSTRY AND THAT
WARY AT TODAY IS WHERE A LOT OF
OTHER INDUSTRIES CAN BECOME.
AND A LIKE A PRINCE MAY BE WHAT
IT IS A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
WARRANT IS PROGRAM IN THE IN
THE. TRADES THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER INDUSTRIES TODAY ONE.
HOSPITALITY. PLEASE SET UP IN
IT WE SHOULD ALLIES WITH
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS OF.
THERE IS SUCH A WAY THAT.
PEOPLE SEE THEMSELVES WITH THE
REAL FUTURE NOT ONLY. I'M GONNA
GO. THAT UP BUT I'M GETTING
RAIN FOR IT AND THROUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING I'M
GETTING TWENTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
PLUS HEALTH PLUS PENSION MEAN
THAT'S SOMETHING TO LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT MOTIVATES YOU
TO THEIR WANTED TO OTHER OTHER
THINGS- AND IN THE CAREER
LADDER SO I GUESS NOT SO MUCH A
QUESTION OF I DO. THE MORE
SPECIFIC THAT YOU COULD GET
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO AS
LEGISLATORS REALLY SPECIFIC- OR
TWO OR THREE REALLY SPECIFIC
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO AS A
TEAM- I REALLY ASK YOU WHETHER
YOU. YOU HAVE A RIGHT NOW OR
NOT GET IT TO US BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SEE YOU SUCCEED AND
EXPAND EVEN MORE. YEAH EVEN IF
IT'S SOMETHING YOU HEARD FROM
THE FIRST PANEL. JOIN TOGETHER
IN THAT ASK RIGHT THE MORE THE
CURE THAT COMES TOGETHER-
WHETHER IT'S ACCOUNTABILITY IN
PROCUREMENT OR CONTRACTING OUT
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE. THAT
CREATES THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL OF YOU
TO CONTINUE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
BUT TO GROW IT AND TO HAVE MORE
PEOPLE PARTICIPATE. SERVICE.
SENATOR I PLACE SENATE. OKAY
FIRST- IT WAS GREAT HEARING
FROM ALL OF YOU AND SHARING
YOUR STORIES AND- SUCCESSES
FROM THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU HAVE
CREATED I THINK IT'S VERY
ALWAYS VERY IMPORTANT HERE-
FROM THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
WORKING ON THE GROUND IN. DAY
TO DAY- IN THESE TRAINING
PROGRAMS- ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IS SO I
REPRESENT THE NORTHEAST SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WHICH INCLUDES
POINT MONSON VALLEY'S SO-
NORTHERN CITY LIMITS A VALET.
AND I FIND THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF THESE TRAINING PROGRAMS
BASED OUT THERE AND MY
CONSTITUENTS IT'S WE HAVE A
HIGH NEED- IN MY COMMUNITY FOR
THESE PROGRAMS AND-
TRANSPORTATION IS A BARRIER IN
A LOT OF TIMES GOING TO
COMMERCE. OR DOWNTOWN LA OR
SOUTH LA IS WOULD TAKE TWO
HOURS OR MORE IN A ON. TO GET
THERE- AND SO ONE OF MY
INTEREST. IS TO BRING PROGRAMS
OUT THERE AND TO WORK WITH
EXISTING ORGANIZATIONS- THAT
THAT LIKE ONE OF YOU SAID. THAT
WE MAY NOT THINK UP AS WORK
FORCE TO. THAT OF GRANT
PROGRAMS IF THEY'RE PUT OUT SAY
FOR THE STATE FUNDING- THEY'D
SOME OF THE ORGANIZATIONS DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO FILL OUT
THE APPLICATION. HE LOOKED AND
WE NEED TO CREATE A SYSTEM OR A
SOME- TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
RATES OF THAT- COMMUNITIES
THERE IN HIGH NEED- GET THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
TO APPLY AND TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLY. WITH THE STATE FUNDING
OR FEDERAL OR OTHER- FUNDING
SOURCES THAT MAY HAVE LIKE A
LOT OF RED TAPE LIKE YOU SAID
RATE. BECAUSE IF YOU'RE A
SMALLER ORGANIZATION THAT
YOU'RE STRAIN IS THE COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS AND YOU KNOW THE
COMMUNITY WHICH IS WHAT I THINK
WE REALLY NEED AND I KNOW SKIP
AND OTHERS YOU BROUGHT THOSE.
AIM POINTS UP BUT THEN THE
GRANT WRITING THEN THE
COMPLIANCE- IS ANOTHER SET OF
SKILLS THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
WORK ON RIGHT LAKE AND THAT'S
ONE OF MY INTEREST TO FIGURE
THAT OUT AND HOW AS A STATE
LEGISLATOR I CAN HELP BECAUSE
OF I. HOPE COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE I KNOW THAT THERE'S MANY
OTHER STATE WIDE THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THE SAME ISSUE AND- AND
SO I'VE STARTED SOME
DISCUSSIONS BUT- YOU KNOW I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU OF ANY
IDEAS OR WHAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL FOR YOU IF. FOR IF
YOU EITHER YOUR ORGANIZATION OR
OTHERS HAVE GONE THROUGH
SIMILAR CHALLENGES. THAT IS
EXCELLENT BECAUSE- BEFORE NINE
YEARS SECOND CALL WAS ALL
VOLUNTARY I ACTUALLY WORKED FOR
THE GREAT OFFICE I WORK FOR THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE AS A GANG
INTERVENTION IS AS WE CREATED
SECOND CALL FOR NINE YEARS.
ABSOLUTELY NO FUN AT ALL- JUST
RECENTLY JANICE HAHN I SAW HER
AT A- AN EVENT IN LONG BEACH
ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO AND- SHE
KNOWS WHO I AM FROM WHEN SHE
WAS CITY COUNCIL. AND SHE TOLD
ME TO GET IN TOUCH WITH OUR
FIELD REP BECAUSE THEY HAVE
MONEY FOR WHAT WE DO. AND BUT I
HAD A PAROLEES WHO DONE
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN PRISON I
JUST WANT MY PAROLE LEAD TO
TAKE A PICTURE WITH JANICE ON
SO I HEARD JANICE BUT I DIDN'T
PAY ATTENTION. BUT WHAT
HAPPENED WAS JANICE HAD HER
FIELD REP LOOK FOR ME PEOPLE
STARTED CALL IN LIKE HEY- HER
LINDA IS LOOKING FOR YOU AND
SHE BROUGHT ME IN AND INNER DO
SMITA DANA GARCETTI WHICH IS.
BIG SISTER. AND THEY KNEW THAT
THE COMMUNITY I'M WORKING WITH
THE PAROLEES AND THEY DID IT
THEY HELPED ME WITH ONLY ARE
AND HELP ME GET A CONTRACT WITH
PROBATION BECAUSE THEY KNEW I
DID NOT KNOW THE PROCESS- SO.
IF I COULD SAY THAT I TAKE MY
HAT OFF TO JENNIFER ON BECAUSE
SHE HAD- PEOPLE CHASE ME TO GET
ME MONEY TO WHERE I AM. NOW
WORK FOR THE CITY OF LA. I WORK
FOR SECOND CALL FULL SCALE- I
THINK THAT'S IT- AT AND WE'VE
HAD SO MUCH HELP FROM THE FLAT
RATE CENTER HAVE TAKE MY HAT
OFF TO JAY LANE MOSTLY AS WELL.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU DO POLICY
OFFICE. WOULD EXPLAIN WAS THIS
IS. A BUDGET NARRATIVE THIS A
BUDGET SUMMARY THIS IS HOW
WE'RE PUTTING YOU IN THE BUDGET
THIS IS WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO.
AND THE YOU KNOW GIVE ME MY
INSTRUCTIONS AND I'LL GET HIM
DONE- BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT I HAVE NOT EVER GOTTEN A
GRANT BECAUSE- EVERYONE ON MY
TEAM HAS DONE SEVENTEEN SEVEN
NINE. TWELVE FIFTEEN YEARS IN
PRISON AND THAT'S JUST WHAT WE
LOVE. WITH AND LEARN HOW TO
WRITE GRANTS. ALSO I JUST SAID
REALLY QUICKLY THAT- THERE'S A
NEW PROGRAM THAT JUST STARTED A
MISSION COLLEGE- AND I ACTUALLY
WENT OUT THERE SPOKE TO THE
CLASS THE INSTRUCTOR IS A
FRIEND OF MINE BUT ANOTHER
PERSON YOU OF FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION ASPECT NOW THERE'S
A WHOLE NOTHER SIDE OF IT WE
KNOW THERE'S A HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS TO THAT'S
A WHOLE DIFFERENT GROUP BUT AS
I FOCUS ON THE CONSTRUCTION
SIDE OF THINGS BUT- CHRIS
HANNAN IF YOU TALK TO HIM- HELP
ESTABLISH AND SET UP A LOT OF
THESE- PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE COUNTY. AND
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND BRINGING
IN THE PARTNERS AT ALL DO WHAT
WE DO- SKIP THE SECOND CALL
FLINT RIDGE WERE WERE ALL AT
MULTIPLE SITES IN DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND WE ALL WORK IN AND
HAVE CAPACITY TO DO THINGS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS SO- WHATEVER THE
NEED IS IN THAT BUT- IT IN A
EAST SAINT LOUIS SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY RIGHT HE. SAID AND
WHATEVER THE NEED IS THERE. WE.
HAVE A RECESSION MY- NUTS
GRADING IT'S GETTING TO THE
PEOPLE GETTING GOING TO THEM.
NOT ASKING PEOPLE TO. GET IN
ABOUT TWO HOURS. ACCESS
SERVICES THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW
NATIONALLY THEY NEED OR NOT.
AND SUCKING IS GREAT TO HEAR
ABOUT THESE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ALREADY EXIST OF WE CAN EXPAND.
FURTHER. BUT BEFORE PUBLIC ON A
COUPLE QUICK I KNOW THAT.
DORIAN YOU TALKED ABOUT SOME
THE WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND I
WAS ONE OF THE QUESTION A DRUG
TESTING ALL THAT BECAUSE YOU
CAN HAVING REPRESENT A LOT OF.
CLIENTS MY PAST WORK- TRUCK
ADDICTION IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT- YOU KNOCK OUT OF THE
FIRST TRIES OR SOME FACTS
ABILITY IF. SOMEONE DOES TEST
TO GET THEM TO PROGRAM SO THAT
THEY CAN GET BACK IN TO THE
TRAINING- ONCE WHEN ONCE THEY
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE-
COUNSELING YES. MOST DEFINITELY
YOU KNOW WE MEET INDIVIDUALS
WHERE THEY ARE SO YOU KNOW
WE'VE HAD INDIVIDUALS DIED-
TESTED DIRTY COULDN'T GET IN
THE PROGRAM ORIGINALLY BUT WE
FOLLOW UP. ON PROVIDE SERVICES
A RESOURCES FOR THEM TO GET
HELP WE'VE HAD INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE IN THE PROGRAM AND TRUSTED
DIRTY. SO YOU KNOW CONSTRUCTION
ZERO TOLERANCE INDUSTRY- SO OF
COURSE WE ARE LET GO FROM THE
PROGRAM BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE NEXT COLOR.
SO WE PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THEM
TO GET HELP AND WE'VE HAD
INDIVIDUALS I'VE HAD INDIVIDUAL.
THREE TRIES FIRST TIME. HE.
TESTED DIRTY IN WEEK SIX ON-
CAME BACK IN TIME TESTER DIRTY
AGAIN. THIRD TIME'S A CHARM YOU
KNOW HE RAN INTO REHAB AND BY
THE TIME NEXT COURT CAME
AROUND. HE WAS CLEAN AND READY
TO GO HE WAS DONE WITH THIS SO
WE DON'T GIVE UP YEAH WE MEET
INDIVIDUALS WHERE THEY ARE WE
DON'T GIVE UP ON A VERY VERY
HAPPY TO HEAR ABOUT THAT- AND
SO HOW MANY. HOW MANY FOLKS
WANT TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC COMMENT
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE COMMENT. ONE
TWO THREE. OKAY SO. WHAT YOU
OWN COME UP TO THE FRONT ROW
HERE AND WE'LL GET A MICROPHONE
OVER TO YOU. AND I'LL HAVE YOU
SPEAK ONE AT A TIME AND WE'LL
GIVE YOU CHIU THREE MINUTES TO
SPEAK SENSORS JUST I THINK A
THREE OF YOU. AND SO- YEAH JUST
WILL GET YOU A MICROPHONE. AND
PLEASE SHARE YOUR COMMENTS YOUR
STONES OF THE US- AND ABBAS RB
OBSERVER THE RECORD AS WELL SO.
THE GENTLEMAN THE GRANT I THINK
THAT HE WAS ASKED TO SPEAKERS
IF YOU WANT TO. START OFF IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE TWO LADIES
NEXT. THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY WELL. I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT HELLO. I WAS FOR ME
INCARCERATED. THE REASON WHY
I'M HERE TODAY IS THE US OPEN
SENEGAL CALIFORNIA AND THEY
SAID I'M UP 21% INDIVIDUAL EVER
GO TO. THEY HAD NEVER USE
ALCOHOL AND DRUG THANKS SO. I
GOT OUT OF PRISON GO TO SAN
DIEGO IF THE LOSS OF THEIR
FUNDING FOR ME TO BE DOWN NEAR.
US TOTAL WILL I'M JUST HAPPY TO
BE OUT OF PRISON YOU SEE ME
ANYWHERE THE I END UP IN LA.
AND IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE I
COMMITTED A HORRIBLE CRIME NO A
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD SPENT TWENTY
YEARS IN PRISON. NEVER HAD A
LIFE NEVER HAD A JOB. THE MOST
WHATEVER HEAD WAS FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND THAT'S BECAUSE. HE
GAVE ME TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS GET
OUT OF PRISON AND. FROM MY
BUDDIES RAISED THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS THE STORE MY NEW LIFE.
I GET A BEER. I GET INTO THIS
IS CORPS PROGRAM. IS THE CHAIR
ALIVE. TEN FIVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE. THANK YOU SET UP
LIKE SANTA I AM WOULD NOT A JOB
BUT A CAREER. OF. I'M MAKING
MORE MONEY THAT IS MY LIFE
HELLO. SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THE BANK NOW. IT WAS. NO IS
STILL WITH. IT WAS A STRUGGLE
BECAUSE AS A CASHIER WITH
DORIAN OF HE'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST IS MORE THAN JUST HE'S
MORE THAN JUST A. THE PROGRAM
THE BIG BROTHER TO ME NO I HAVE
ALL MY CHECKS ARE. GOING TO THE
BANK. THE CZECH REPUBLIC'S
BUYER OF ACCORDING MORE. THIS
IS A DOCTOR GOT. THE MAYES
CALLS FOR YOUR. IN ORDER TO THE
BANK AND ALL THE BANK ACCOUNT.
WHAT IS DIFFERENT THINGS BUT.
I'M GONNA LABOR LABOR NUMBER
TEN. BECAUSE THE DOORS OPEN IN
THE PROGRAM ALWAYS CREDIT
DORIAN WE WENT WAY BEYOND
BEYOND WHAT THE PROGRAM
REQUIRES LOW I'LL HAVE NO
PETITIONS I HAVE NO FAMILY
MEMBER. IN LA. I NEED TO DO TO
WAS TO TURN AN APPLICATION GET
GET INTO THE BOOK CAM. I GOT TO
CAME IN PIC DROVE ME WAY THAT
ON THERE AND- TOOK ME TO LUNCH
AND WILL BE BACK SOON. LIFE IS.
IT'S BEEN FOREVER SINCE IT'S
BEEN IT'S BEEN A FOR NOT A LOT
OF GUYS GET OUT OF PRISON BUT
FOR ME LIFE HAS BEEN PERFECT
MAN. THEY ARE SEE SOMEONE MAKE
UP THERE ARE PROP PRESET
EVERYTHING THE BILL FOR ME IN.
YOU GUYS DID YOU GUYS YOU GUYS
GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
MY LIFE I GOT EVERYTHING YOU
NEED SOMEBODY HAS NEVER BEEN A
PRETTY HEAD. DO FOR BEING A
PHASE I GET A HUNDRED DOLLAR
PENSION JULY CAMINO SKINNER
DECEMBER FIRST. A ME ME TO BE A
VACATION SIX NEW. LIKE I DON'T
BELIEVE OKAY BELIEVE IT YOU
KNOW ONLY BEEN WORKING SINCE
THE LINE YOU KNOW. POSSIBLE TO
THANK YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN YOU
GUYS DO. IS THIS IS MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN MY. A NEW
OPPORTUNITY BLOOM LEASE ON LIFE.
WHAT WAS YOUR NAME. THE NEW
CLEAN SAMUEL CAME CAME. MY
BROTHER I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT.
CLEARLY DORIAN WILL TO GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND AND HE DESERVES A
LOT OF CREDIT BUT NO ONE
DESERVES MORE CREDIT THAN YOU
FOR TURN YOUR LIFE AROUND. I
WOULD VENTURE I WOULD VENTURE
TO GUESS THAT YOU DIDN'T GET
WHAT YOU DESERVE YOU FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS. AND SO YOU
EARNED EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE
GETTING NOW- I DON'T THINK ANY
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD SHOULD EVER
SPEND TWENTY NINE YEARS IN
PRISON I DON'T CARE WHAT THEY
DID. THE FACT THAT YOU'RE ABLE
TO TURN YOUR LIFE AROUND. I
MEAN I WANT TO TAKE YOU ON THE
ROAD WITH ME TO TELL PEOPLE
THAT YOU NEVER GIVE UP ON
ANYONE. AND SO THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THE STORY I KNOW IT'S
NOT EASY TO SHARE. SOME OF
THOSE PERSONAL THINGS ABOUT
YOURSELF. BUT BUT- YOU DESERVE
TO BE COMMENDED THESE PROGRAMS
ARE TO BE COMMENDED. BILLION
EVERYONE THAT WAS THERE WITH
YOU BUT- THEY WOULDN'T DO IT
UNLESS AS OTHER POTENTIAL IN
YOU- AND SO THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY. THANK YOU.
HI I HAVE A QUICK COMMENT AND A
QUESTION. MY COMMENT JUST
SPECIFIC PLEASE I THINK TO
SERVICES NOTHING FERNANDO
VALLEY I USED TO- UNTIL
RECENTLY TEACH AT THE PAROLE
OFFICE IN VAN NUYS- BUT WHERE I
SPENT. MOST OF MY DAYS SORT OF
GETTING PEOPLE CONNECTED TO PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TALKING
ABOUT THEM. GETTING THEM SCHOOL
READY SO THEY COULD APPLY FOR
THEM- CDC ARE CUT THOSE
PROGRAMS COMPLETELY SO THERE'S
NO MORE LITERACY LAPSE IN ANY
OF THE PRO OFFICES- INTENSIVE
LEGISLATORS HERE I JUST WANT TO
PUT THAT ON YOUR RADAR WHAT WAS
THE NAME OF THE PROGRAM. WELL
IT USED TO BE. LET LAB. AND
LIKE A DRUG TREATMENT PROGRAM.
AND BY CONTRAST COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION THEY CANCEL THAT
CONTRACT SO NOW WITH NO PAROLE
OFFICES IN THE STATE HAVE A
LITERACY OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROGRAM AND HOUSE OBVIOUSLY.
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF PRISON ARE
GOING TO PAROLE SO IT'S ONE OF
THOSE LOCATIONS THAT SHOULD
HAVE- SERVICES THAT WILL
CONNECT HIM TO THESE PROGRAMS
THEY DON'T ANYMORE. IN MY OTHER
QUESTION WAS JUST ABOUT WHERE
DO YOU HOW MUCH THOUGHT IS
GIVEN TO WHEN THE TIMES ARE
OVER- AND THERE'S NOT SO MUCH
DEMAND FOR CONSTRUCTION JOBS
IN. HOW MUCH OF THE TRAINING IS
PREPARING PEOPLE TO BE NIMBLE
AND- THE MOVE INTO OTHER
POSITIONS WHEN. CONSTRUCTION
JOBS AREN'T PLENTIFUL. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I THINK THAT
SOME OF WHAT'S COME UP- BUT WE
TALK ABOUT HOME CARE AIDES IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT WE SEE IS
GROWTH INDUSTRIES YESTERDAY IN
THE COMMISSION HEARING- WE
LOOKED AT A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT GROWTH INDUSTRIES AND
HEALTHCARE- HOME CARE CHILD
CARE- THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY
UNDERPAID A LOT OF WASTE OF
FULL OF THE AND A LOT OF A
WOMEN IN THOSE POSITIONS
CERTAINLY FAR MORE THAN YOU SEE
IN THE- CONSTRUCTION TRADES BUT
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT. THAT
WE HAVE TO REMIND OURSELVES
THAT WE HAVE TO BE DIVERSE IN
THE KINDS OF TRAINS WE DO I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW IF ON A IF
YOU HAVE ANY. FURTHER IS THE
INSIDE IN THAT IN TERMS OF
TRAINING BEYOND OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OUR BUILDING TRADES AND BUT FOR
THE CONDOM IS GO UP AND DOWN
WITH THAT OFTENTIMES
CONSTRUCTION JOBS GO UP AND
DOWN SO- IF YOU HAVE ANY
INSIGHT AS TO THE FROM THE
LABOR CENTERS PERSPECTIVE OF
CERTAIN FIELDS THAT. YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO IN. ADDITION TO THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES FOCUS ON AS
WELL. I KNOW THE HOSPITALITY
TRAINING ACADEMY THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA MORE FOR DEVELOPMENT.
PARTNERSHIP INITIATIVE IS
CREATING A RECALL SYSTEM FOR
HOME CARE- A HOME OF ATTENDANCE
THAT WILL KEEP THEM YOU'RE
WORKING YOU'RE AROUND SO THE
WORKING WITH OTHER OR WITH
OTHER- EMPLOYERS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THEM WORK YEAR ROUND SO
THERE'S PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. TESTING DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE TO CONNECT
PEOPLE TO FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU YEAH BUT I THINK IT'S
AN EXCELLENT POINT THAT WE DO-
AND I THINK THAT AS A SENATOR
INDICATE EARLIER NO SOME. SAUCE
MISSION AS WELL THE BUILDING
TRADES MODEL. TO SHIP MODEL-
NEEDS TO BE EXPANDED AND UNDER
THE INDUSTRY'S HOTEL INDUSTRIES
CHILD CARE I THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO CREATE A
BASELINE OF STABILITY OF
EMPLOYMENT. AND SUCH IN THE
BUILDING TRADES HAVE SHOWN US
THE TEMPLATE- WHEN YOU'RE NOT
ONLY EXPAND. THOSE BUILDING
TRADES PROFESSIONS
OPPORTUNITIES BUT USE THAT
TEMPLATE. FOR OTHER INDUSTRIES
TO EMPOWER THOSE WORKERS AS
WELL. YES PLEASE. HI GOOD
MORNING- I AM ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT FOR SMELL WHEN
EATING ANY SERVICES THAT'S COOL
HI MY NAME IS WELL THE WAIT
TIME THE EXTERNAL RELATIONS
MANAGER I WANTED TO COMMEND ALL
PRESENTING AGENCIES FOR THEIR
TRANSFORMATIONAL WORK AND
COMMITMENT TO CITY JAKE
PARTNERSHIPS TO SERVE LA COUNTY
RESIDENTS. I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE SOME TIME TO HIGHLIGHT FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THE MULTIPLE
INITIATIVES ARE DEPARTMENT OF
FLEETING ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY TO EXPAND CAREER
PATHWAYS TO ECONOMIC PROSPERITY
FOR RESIDENTS WORKERS AND.
BUSINESSES IN HIGH GROWTH
SECTORS THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES.
THE MOST POPULOUS COUNTY IN THE
NATION. THE COUNTY HAS LAUNCHED
A HOMELESS- TO HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM ENTITLED
HIGHER UP THE PROGRAM TAKES TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EXPERIENCE I
MEAN INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND TRAINS THEM TO
SIX- BE SUCCESSFUL IN UNION
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES
ACROSS THREE HIGH GROWTH SECTOR
INDUSTRIES ALL WHY PROVIDING
STIPENDS INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND FLEXIBLE CASES
AS A CASH ASSISTANCE FOR LAST
MINUTE EMERGENCIES. THAT ARISE
DURING THE PROGRAM HIGHER UP
WILL PROVIDE RETENTION SUPPORT
FOR INDIVIDUALS ONCE THEY ARE
PLACED IN HYBRID CAREERS AND
WE'LL TRACK POST PLACEMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE COUNTY HAS
INITIATED A GREEN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM FOCUSING
ON CAREER PATHWAYS AND GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE ELECTIVE VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING AND HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS REMEDIATION WE ARE
WORKING WITH LA METRO OUR
PARTNERS IN PRIVATE INDUSTRY
AND OUR FELLOW COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS TO CREATE A
PIPELINE. OF INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT WHO WILL BE READY
FOR MANY JOBS BEING CREATED BY
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE MEASURES
SUCH AS W. A AND M. AS WELL AS
SB ONE AND THE STAGE TO A
CARBON NEUTRAL ECONOMY- THESE
ARE JUST THE VERY FEW PROGRAMS
THAT I'M SORT OF HIGHLIGHTING
AND PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT BUT WE HAVE
THE HIGHER ALLIE X. PROGRAM
THAT WE ALSO PARTNER WITH. TOM
THE JAIL BASED JOBCENTRE
WOMEN'S. CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO WILL BE
WHERE WE. TO TRY AND WOMEN AND
WHILE IN THE INSIDE FOR. ALL AN
AIRY- TECHNOLOGY AND
CONSTRUCTION- AS WELL AS A CNA-
PROGRAM OF FINALLY THE COUNTY
HAS PARTNERED WITH LED SEE AND
THE LA AREA CHAMBER AN ALLEY
METRO TO RAISE AWARENESS AND
CREATE MEANINGFUL PARTNERSHIPS
TRUMP PLAMEN ACCORDING FOR THE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED IN
SEPTEMBER THE COUNTY LAUNCHED A
FAIR CHANCE HIRING CAMPAIGN. TO
BOTH RAISE AWARENESS OF THE
FAIR CHANCE ACT AND PARTNER
WITH EMPLOYERS TO HIRE FROM THE
JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATION THE
CAMPAIGN HIGHLIGHTS A POSITIVE
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS INVOLVED
IN HIRING JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS WHY PROVIDING
PUBLIC ISSUE AWARENESS AND
TRAINING OPTIONS TO JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS- WE JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. AND
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH STATE AND MUNICIPAL PASS
PARTNERS TO FURTHER OUR
COLLECTIVE GOALS THANK YOU MY
SON WAS GOING AROUND ESPECIALLY
FOR BURKE SAYING ON A- SAD TO
ME WAS KIND OF SPOKE AROUND
ANONYMOUSLY DIRECTLY TO ONE IS
HOMELESSNESS ALL THE PROGRAMS
HERE BECAUSE OF COURSE YOU KNOW
THOSE WERE FAMILY INCARCERATED
THOSE AT THAT AGE OUT OF FOSTER
CARE. HAVE A MUCH HIGHER RATE
OF HOMELESSNESS ALL THE
PROGRAMS HERE AND AS A WAY TO
APPROACH AND REALLY ATTACK
HOMES HAS HAD ON A BUT ALSO ON
THE SOME OF THE GREEN
TECHNOLOGY ASPECTS THAT AS WE
BASS MORNING GREEN TECHNOLOGIES
IN THE NEW ECONOMY WE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ALSO MAKE
IT WILL ENSURE THAT THOSE ARE
LABOR JOBS UNION JOBS. GOOD
HIGH QUALITY JOBS ESPECIALLY
FOR SUBSIDIZING THEM WITH
TAXPAYER DOLLARS- BUT BEFORE I
CLICKED I JUST I WANTED AND IF
YOU KNOW DANIEL I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU- LIKE TO BUT I WHAT I JUST
WANT TO ASK YOU GEN OF. BECAUSE
WE BECAUSE OF MY STORY AND WAS
TALK MY BREAKING THAT CYCLE THE
NATION- POVERTY IN YOU SPOKE TO
IT AS WELL AND YOU MENTION YOUR.
TWO KIDS WHEN YOU GOT RELEASED
TO HAVE THESE TWO KIDS. MY
BOOTS OFF FOR ME. AND I HAVE
THREE KIDS NOW. THAT'S WHAT
IT'S ABOUT RIGHT IS ABOUT THAT
IN A GENERATION LIFTING UP THE
NEXT GENERATION BY LIFTING
OURSELVES UP THE BEST WE CAN
I'M A IN BEFORE I CLOSE IN THE
REVERSE YOU LIKE LIKE. THE SAME
THING CLOSE. YOU KNOW I LEARNED
SO MUCH TODAY JUST HEARING YOUR
STORIES I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE THAT PRESENTED- IT'S
VERY INSPIRING FOR US ON THE
LABOR COMMITTEE. TO GO IN
JANUARY RIGHT- THANK YOU TO OUR
CHAIR FOR ORGANIZING THIS IN
LOS ANGELES- YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
ON THE LABOR COMMITTEE EVER
SINCE I. STARTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I GET TO HEAR
THIS. ON THE STORIES AND WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT- AND
IT'S VERY VERY MOTIVATING AS A
MEMBER- TO GO AND NOW START UP
IN JANUARY AND SEE. HOW WE CAN
HELP AND HOW WE CAN PARTNER
WITH COMMUNITIES LABOR- AND
OTHERS- YOU KNOW TO REALLY MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA SO
THANK YOU. FOR PROVIDING THAT
INSPIRATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOME A MEMBER RIVAS OF MILES
MORE THANKS AMERICANS ALWAYS
SPOKE LABOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO ARE. WHO ARE HERE TODAY OF
COURSE SENATOR TO ROSS SO AS
WELL YOUR IN OUR IN TRUMP'S WE
LOOK BACK INTO SESSION JANUARY
BUT- I- WE WORKED WITH
INTRAMOLECULAR THESE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS. TO
BETTER INFORM US WHEN WE SHOW
UP AND GENERALLY WE KNOW WHAT
MONEY TO ASK MORE WE KNOW WHAT
BILLS TO PROPOSE. TO ACTUALLY
HELP THOSE OF YOU DOING THE
WORK ON THE GROUND- SO WE'RE
NOT STUCK IN THE SACRAMENTO
BUBBLE THINKING THAT WE KNOW
WHAT'S BEST. YOU ALL FOR THE
FIRST PANEL OF THIS PANEL YOU
KNOW WHAT'S WORKING. YOU CAN
TELL US WHAT'S WORKING WE NEED
TO HELP YOU- AND I JUST WANNA
SAY THAT I'M SELLING COURAGE.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER- YOU
KNOW I WAS DEBBIE PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR ELEVEN YEARS FROM
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. I NEVER
WOULD'VE IMAGINED FIRST OF ALL
THE BILL'S WE'VE GOTTEN PAST
THE LAST FEW YEARS TO DEEP CAR
SERRATE OUR STATE TO GO FROM
THE INCARCERATION CAPITAL- INTO
ENDED THAT. HERBAL LEGACY THAT
WE'VE CREATED OF LOCKING PEOPLE
UP FOR POOR PEOPLE UP. I AM
VERY GRATEFUL TO BE THAT
GOVERNOR'S AND LEGISLATION
LEGISLATORS THAT HAVE SUPPORTED
THAT EFFORT. BUT THE OTHER SIDE
OF IS IT OKAY WHAT WE DO NEXT
TO REINVEST IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
INVESTING IN OUR PEOPLE- AND
ALL OF YOU HAVE BEEN A PART OF
THAT. ALL OF YOU ARE GOING TO
BE PART OF THE JOURNEY. GOING
FORWARD AND SO THIS INCREDIBLE
RACIAL. AND LIGHTNING IT HELPS
AND FOR ME. TO USE AND OTHERS
SO WE SHOW UP IN JANUARY WE
KNOW HOW TO FIGHT BETTER FOR
ALL THE WORK. ALL OF YOU. ARE
DOING. I DO. ONE OTHER. THING I
MIGHT CONSULTANT MEGAN LANE AND
PRINCIPLE- BECAUSE TO MY RIGHT.
AND PRINCIPAL SO AND JUSTIN
DEALER CREWS. OF PUTTING A LOT
OF WORK INTO MAKING TODAY
POSSIBLE. I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PANELISTS WHO TAKE THEIR
TIME OUT. TO BE HERE TO BETTER
INFORM US AS I SAID THIS IS
ALL. NOT JUST BEING LIVE
STREAMED BUT ARCHIVED BUT FOR
THE BENEFIT OF OUR STAFF. AS
WELL AS OTHERS THAT ARE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU AROUND THE
STATE ESPECIALLY RURAL
COMMUNITIES CENTRAL VALLEY
NORTH. BUT HONESTLY HAVE THE
BENEFIT. OF WHAT THE OTHER
BUILDING TRADES AND OTHERS CAN
BRING TO THE TABLE WE WANT TO
SHARE AND CONNECT WITH THEM LET
THEM KNOW THAT THEY CAN DO IT.
AND WERE THERE TO HELP AS WELL
AND I THINK THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER- FOR BEING HERE AND
FOR- FOR STREAMING IT AND
MAKING SURE- THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS DISSEMINATED- TO
EVERYONE THAT WANTS TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH US- SO IT IS.
TWELVE O'CLOCK ON THE DOT.
THANK YOU ALL. SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THIS WORK WITH
YOU